drip
crush taste has drip now let's go you
can get your very own trash taste merch
now we have promoted apari a ton on this
channel and we love their clothes we
love it so much that we decided we'd
partner up with them and make some trash
taste slash a parry mo hell yeah look at
that look at that god i love that design
so much oh my god so you we have the
normal i am wearing the regular trash
taste design and gun over there is
wearing the after dog i've got the after
dark version oh so cute but don't worry
if you're living in a hot area we also
have t-shirts as well look at connor
wearing his beautiful lavender one this
is my personal favorite my recording it
looks very nice we literally needed to
get this custom dyed to get trash taste
perfect trash taste purple design oh so
clean but if you need something a little
more cozy you know you're thinking like
you want to get a bit of warmth hell
yeah
sweatpants now these are the uh
prototype version so the embroidery
isn't on there but there will be a trash
taste logo embroidering on it got to say
boys this is some high quality
everything is so cold speaking of the
embroidery look at this look look how
cute this is so cute you have the apari
little character sitting on the trash
taste and after darkness you got
embroidery on the t-shirts as well so
you don't have to worry about it fading
because it's embroidered in look at it
it can never fade you know it is
obviously a little more pricey than our
previous merch but it is such high
quality you are going to get the best
quality merch and these are the people
who have bought aparri stuff before as
it normally sells out whenever we
promote it you'll know the apari stuff
is good quality and i promise it's worth
the price tag and guys we heard you we
heard you like the postcards so we
decided to give everyone a personalized
postcard this time
signed by the boys yeah but the first
thousand will get a special postcard
we're not gonna spoil what's on it but
they're gonna get a special one the ssr
of postcards
and of course they're gonna be numbered
we're still waiting for number 69 and
number 420 to make themselves known for
the trash these guys come out
so what are you waiting for go and get
your merch by using the link down below
and uh yeah i hope you uh get dripped
out with the be quick because there's
only three weeks in pre-order oh [ __ ] i
forgot to mention that yeah there's only
three weeks later these will not be
around forever so click that link in the
description grab them while you can
orders ends at the end of the year so
it's easy for you to know when this deal
ends 2022 rolls over you will not see
these merch so grab a quick link in the
description get that trash taste get
your trust as much do it drip out on
with the episode i have zero expectation
man if i get 10 twitter followers after
this i'm [ __ ] happy this must be
something wrong with you that's the case
yeah it's his fault yeah it's definitely
his phone it's like well [ __ ] that guy
i'm dead on the inside welcome to trash
taste podcast wow that was that was an
intro
yeah you guys were like oh what happened
to the joey intros man i want them back
so i brought them back
we've gone from like combini i'm not
gonna say the words to uh i'm dead
inside how how did we go from one side
to the other joke it makes no sense
tragic evolution yeah that's what
happens man when you do trash taste for
that long that's why we have devolved
we've devolved yeah uh i'm joey and as
always i'm with the other two people who
are dead inside gone and connor you're
making me dead inside no no who's our
guest
i don't know introduce yourself well
what's up guys it's your homie john aka
sushi kebab guy
nice to meet you all today how are you
so jan is a friend of ours a mutual
friend of ours um and you are or you
were a host
yeah yeah i mean i mean
we met you through mutual friends but
like you know when you you know when you
meet someone in your life and you just
think like wow you're one of the most
interesting people i've ever met thank
you because like you're jan's one of
those people who you when whenever you
go to a party whenever you speak to him
he'll have a new story every [ __ ]
time i'm like i don't know how you do it
but like because we've hung out so many
times and every time we hang out you
come out with a new story about
something that's happened in your life
even on this podcast there's so many
questions i want to ask about your just
like life experience here in japan
because like unlike
any of our previous guests jan doesn't
have an internet presence true yeah yes
yes yes so you know yeah so
understandable that uh he's a bit
nervous uh go go he's in it go easy on
him but it's also like how often do you
just like come across a dude who used to
be a host yeah because like i feel
that's just like a part of like japanese
subculture life that you just don't hear
about right yeah it seems very very
japanese and from what i saw is
extremely japanese yeah the also the
only i feel the only time you would ever
get to know a host is if you yourself
end up going to a host club enough that
you get to know a host right and i mean
the three of us don't i mean almost no
foreigners become hosts anyway like even
if you're half like me yeah yeah no one
really like applies to become one yeah
so you're half turkish half champion
half cherokee stuff japanese so
if any turkish people watching what's up
but turkey's represent let's go oh you
got him man is that part of turkey's
culture because hell yeah any time any
time we go out and we're with jan he
meets he meets another turkish person
for sure it's like they're local
and like you get free [ __ ] and like you
take care of them they take care of you
and i'm just like what is going on it's
like the world's strongest magnets
they're just like they're just like from
distance they're like oh there you are i
remember we had a restaurant one time
and they were like you gotta leave in
like one hour and then um the the guy
the manager of the restaurant was
turkish
that's right it was like the moment that
he found that out it was like the guy
was like oh no no you stay as long as
you want
whatever you want to do
you know it's like what what is this bro
what is this this is insane they they
actually wanted to move us if you
remember yeah they did yeah oh yeah
so i think we managed to stay in our
spot like they moved the guests away you
know yeah
actually not like people [ __ ] booked
that place you know i'm like we're going
over our time and then they told the
guests like these guys you know they're
not going to move how about you let's go
there
like i mean japanese people know that
yeah they go to that guest like are you
a jan i didn't think so
i i think where if you hang out with you
one thing you notice is that uh yeah
you're not very japanese in certain ways
yeah well i mean i hope so but like you
should that's but that's almost you know
being a host requires you to be
extremely ex extroverted yeah and i
think that applies to you
i've never seen someone haggle in japan
yeah but this man
this man
i didn't even know you were like allowed
to haggle in japan until i saw january
hey you gotta try it right and then see
what happens yeah right but like just
just based on like just pre-assumptions
of how japanese like you know that kind
of stuff in japan works right it's like
i i was watching you haggle for the
first time like i was scared i was like
you're doing something illegal yeah yeah
it just looks so wrong yeah i'm just
like sometimes you go out with jan and
i'm just like i didn't know you could do
this yeah because it just wasn't part of
like the rule sets that i was taught
in japanese culture but i mean i guess
that's how you found yourself in the
position like becoming a host i mean you
know it's yeah yeah we should go we
should go like the back story of how jam
i guess how you
first of all like ended up coming to
japan sure because you were you born in
japan i know i was born in turkey
actually okay so i was born and raised
in turkey until i was like 16. um
japanese school until 7th grade and then
international school until 10th grade
and then i moved to united arab emirates
dubai that's how they will say okay so i
was in dubai for two years came back to
turkey for uni for two years
went to czech republic and then on my
final year i went to joe today
so tokyo all right i graduated here and
then just decide to stay here so i was
in jochi um and then you know what is
that graduation
yeah
yeah i was interested in it it's like
yeah it's like a central central tokyo
university university bro like one of
the four you know hottest chicks in
tokyo that's that's what they say
ancient university what are they called
university the hottest chick no no they
there's like talk in terms of hottest
girls
so we clearly know why he decided to go
to this uni so you were born a host i
guess
no okay so i'm a [ __ ] introvert guys
shut up bro
actually
that's the biggest lie of the century
this guy has been on youtube for five
minutes yeah he's claiming to be an
introvert
come on like actual introverts watching
this show like get the [ __ ] out of here
dude like you are not one of us
like
the intel the internet has ruined the
term introvert yeah because now everyone
claims to be an introvert now we have a
little [ __ ] heart you can't just say
you're an introvert to try and be humble
i love just being by myself who doesn't
okay you know see the thing is like you
know i feel the need to hang out you
know i understand that yeah
because if i don't i don't get to make
new friends i don't get to do fun stuff
yeah yeah but when i'm like outside
hanging out with people i should you're
not like 95 of the time i'm almost like
i'd rather be at home play you know
league of legends or some [ __ ] or you
know like watch anymore that doesn't
make you an introvert that just makes
you unsociable
i don't even want to play league you
know
i definitely don't maybe he is
introverted
dude that's what i'm saying bro like i
shouldn't you not i i do spend a lot of
time outside socializing with people
because i also do enjoy that no no okay
but like i think i think you unders you
need to understand
an introverted person is incapable of
being social no no no no no yeah because
because of because either because they
don't have the confidence to be social
or because they don't know how to that's
that's how i see an introvert like like
i i think that's like obviously if
you're introverted you know you're
an introvert doesn't mean like you're
scared of social interaction you know
that might be some introverts yeah
that's not like that's not everything
the scale you know yeah there's severity
yeah yeah yeah but like i'd say i'm an
introvert and the best way i can
describe it is that you know i can be a
social person but i have i have this
battery right it's it's my social
battery right and if i don't interact
with people for a long time that battery
like it fills up to the point where it
starts like overflowing to be like okay
i just want to go out and talk right
but when i go out and socialize that
battery depletes and depletes more and
depletes more and sometimes just it just
gets completely [ __ ] empty like you
boys have hang out with me sometimes
where i'm just like i'm just not going
to say a word this time hang on i'm
hanging out i'm just i'm just like you
guys can just talk and i'm just going to
sit here
is that is that does it have to do with
being introverted though yeah because
because i feel even extroverts like that
no i if you're tired yeah what i feel
with what i've heard about extroverts
that they actually get energy from
interest from social interaction so they
start off the day with an empty battery
and then they go out and socialize and
that's how they energize themselves
right i feel okay yeah so so if i'm
alone for too long i start to get like
like sad and [ __ ] yeah right do you now
yeah so so yeah connor's definitely
bro guys you know i i invited this guy
well i invited myself over to his house
if there's one thing you need to know
about dan you don't invite jen
to watch the [ __ ] finals well not the
finals but you know tivon versus don
juan it was a league of legends
yeah so you know because i heard this
guy mention that you know he feels
lonely people don't hit him no no no no
no no
no that's missing he has no friends i
got you man let's watch some league
let's have a nice drink together let's
hang out and he's like ah you know
excuses no no no no no no no no that's
not what happened
and then i i went to the thing and it
yeah it wasn't it wasn't that good i
rather wish i watched the league of
legends yeah that's what we were telling
me and i was like oh well yeah
so like going back to the host thing and
you know your your backstory for say so
you are half japanese half turkish yeah
so your mum taught you japanese um my
dad is japanese actually ah okay okay
yeah and my mom's turkish you know
so you are so you because you're
if i think about her i gotta say
something nice i'm sure she's a lovely
lady that's cute yeah so like how did
you get fluent because you're pretty
damn fluent oh
as someone who also is you know half not
i'm not even half actually my parents
my you know what i'm half
about to be like what are you half with
my parents are fully tied but i grew up
in a different yeah yeah
so it's half in a sense but like i'm
full blooded side but still i grew up in
another culture and i'm i wouldn't say
i'm like fully fluent in thai yeah yeah
um so if you're fluent in a you know i
say like your mother tongue language
like joey is you really have to go out
and study it true so how did you get
fluent in it well
you know i lived in turkey so i didn't
really have to study it yeah because i'm
like surrendered by it yeah but japanese
so um starting from first grade i was
enrolled in a japanese school until
seventh grade right and my dad never
spoke to me in any other language you
know right he was so persistent to just
speak to me in japanese that yeah that's
exactly how my mom did it yeah bro yeah
great parenting yeah exactly now we're
flying bro look at us look at us look at
us feel different
yeah no but yeah i i agree that like
that is that is the 100 the way to do it
because any other method if you slip up
with another language then it just lets
the kid know oh i can get away with just
speaking
fluent though because i swear you you're
fluent that that takes you up to a
certain level but it doesn't get you
like oh i mean yeah you obviously have
to study it as well yeah i did a lot i'm
sure you did as well yeah dude so my dad
um
so to go over the story there were like
chores that i can earn money out of by
filling out kanji
so like that they're kind of studying
[ __ ] textbooks if i like got one
correct i would get like 0.5 turkish
liras which is like you know like 10 yen
or some [ __ ] yeah so you know you got
money for studying well like
i i i
i just got my meal for the day
i didn't that wasn't a reward in my
house that was like an obligation he was
in a pay-to-win house yeah right
i was like
he came out of the womb haggling
he's like mother cradle trade off a
mother
i complete kanji test you give me money
[Music]
but yeah i think that was one of the
biggest incentives for me to actually
learn
money is a big incentive for a lot of
things you know absolutely yeah because
at that age as well like even you know
like 10 cents is like whoa well you know
yeah for sure
like you're trying to get your like ice
cream money for the day you know yeah
yeah that's what you're like focused on
how did you how did you decide on a
pricing system where you're just like yo
i'll learn ten counting did that
actually i actually had to haggle with
that
obviously so actually you know now that
you guys talk about it yeah actually i
want to kind of go on a huge tangent oh
okay this is trash
you know whenever i went to your house i
can get with you know all of us and
whatnot yeah there would always be a
period where it's only you and me yeah
on your balcony and we're like
reflecting on our lives yeah
it's it's it's it's like the 5 a.m tour
i'm always gone by like three yeah yeah
yeah i know you're always just like yeah
peace out but then you know gorgeous
always like bro why are you so [ __ ] up
tell me about it
you know what calling me out now
you were asking that to me you know
really really helped me you know go over
stuff with you because i mean it's a new
perspective that you're adding here
right oh thank you man
like how how i know when i'm going to
bed when i hang out with jan is when i
see the sun
that is how that's like well the sun's
kind of coming up jen i should probably
get get to bed right now i just i just
love how you just you found out how
[ __ ] up your life was because god was
like why are you so [ __ ] up bro
well like he really you know
in detail fashion he went over certain
like aspects of what we talked about you
know how i ended up doing certain things
some decision making
and you know really like put your own
thought into your answers and your
evaluation that
made me kind of understand oh thank you
good father figure yeah he's a good
follower father finger slash therapist i
would say
i'm just a big brother come on no
i'm not i'm not a dad yeah guys
i'm not a dad yeah he's the one
is the wisest person i know yeah
i'd say so i think it's the zen like
monk statement yeah that's very true god
just sees things like differently i
don't know hits differently he sees
things through his third eye he does bro
he does except for food
he sees through he sees strings through
his third eye but his other two wise he
doesn't see [ __ ]
but i'll just disagree with him
one random question do people still pick
on you for the way you drink stuff yeah
i mean i mean okay okay have you seen
that
here's the thing here's the thing uh in
my entire life no one has ever picked on
me for the way i drink stuff and now
only only as trash data started has
people have i noticed how i drink things
and i've never noticed that before yeah
uh before i started trash taking on the
camera thank you
you are kind of forced to strive for
perfection on this show like
any one slip up in our audience gotcha i
don't care
so damn you got like fluent and kanji i
guess similar to joey can't write for
[ __ ] though you can't write but you can
read kanji right yeah yeah
the language yeah when i speak to jan
it's like he clearly also gets the
culture i think that's because we both
follow anime manga you know that might
be into that [ __ ] yeah but i mean it
also helps again that your dad you know
did that whole choo choo choo japanese
technique which i honestly would
recommend to any parent yeah no yeah i
mean it's there's two examples that have
been proven to work right it's a must
man
honestly i think so when did you move to
japan originally to like come live here
um so i would visit every year to see my
grandparents and hang out here and i
think that's one of the reasons also why
you know that there's no other cultural
gap
my vocabulary for example yeah yeah but
i moved here permanently about three
years ago so right after you know
graduating from jochi
um you know to actually start working
here mm-hmm
when you became a host
no so that's that
that's never been my like main
profession yeah so it's like a side
hustle uh yeah basically how long did
you get full time
of course i started after 18.
yeah of course of course started any
time before that but um so
so it's been how long seven years since
i started i guess uh because i'm 25 now
is that is that a long time for a host
like what's like the average that a host
would be a host fully dude it really
depends on the club but i would say like
the general lifespan of a single host is
pretty short yeah it seems like all
right can last this yeah honestly really
hard but the thing is like in my case
for example you know i would i wasn't
like a full-time right yeah like for
example until i moved here permanently
it was always like a
summer one-month thing
so for like the audience or like the
customers it was like oh my god i can
only see this dude one month out of the
whole year that that's crazy because for
me it's like i
during my breaks i would just like go
and play xbox like the whole time i i
didn't even have the capacity to even
find jan was on that grind
how did you even like so so you became a
host you said like what for one month
for summer
from like how did that yeah
get into like
i'm so curious okay so to go over um
since you know even before i was 18 i
would always go to kabukicho
yeah yeah the red light district exactly
the closest thing to that that's where
all the amalgamation of all the you know
fun cool [ __ ] in tokyo happens and
sketchy stuff yeah
also very scary yeah but you know like i
would hear stories from my dad how this
street was because my dad used to work
there too at a bar called saboten my dad
is like a huge ass [ __ ] he was
like a bouncer for one of the you know
bars back in the day so he would tell me
how he used to play a card with like you
know
people who are missing a portion of
their finger right right there
so i was really curious to see like what
is this place like now so i would go
there with my origin
i mean just to look around you know
so i would go there and like the people
there just you know treated me like i'm
an adult you know right like i mean it
don't be like that when you're like half
turkish yeah exactly you have a [ __ ]
beard like this yeah yeah if you're a
phd you're 40 years old in japan yeah
exactly exactly i never had an issue
like buying or doing anything here you
know yeah yeah so
yeah outside some i would go there just
to experience what it's like you know
see places it's not like i did anything
or just you know looking yeah um and
then you know
once i turned 18 i decided well when i'm
going to japan i should probably make
some money meaning i should do some
vital yeah because my dad was like well
now that you're 18 i ain't gonna give
you any money bro just do something yeah
you know so i was like all right am i
going to work at a you know [ __ ]
pizzaia yeah or hosto and then i decided
to choose the wait why would the why was
that your two options okay there's more
choices so when i was 18
my father i will work for dominoes
or the sketchiest bar in tokyo
which one should i choose extremes yeah
will you put it like that it's like it's
not my first two choices
okay okay so to go over why that just
went to mcdonald's
the way it transpired is that um when i
turned 18 near my parents house there
was a pieza called
i'm not going to name it because it's my
surname
uh
pizza pizza yeah okay i understood that
that was it but i just really make sure
yeah yeah it's a pizza shop so the
shop's name was literally my surname so
i went there chat with the guy he's like
yo we have the same surname and he looks
like exactly like me bro this guy
japanese has a beard huge nose and
everything was he talking so no he's not
he's not but when we came really good
friends and he was like why don't you
work here you know i heard you're here
for the summer you know i'll give you
good cash 900 in an hour yeah
like it's like 10 bucks yeah but it was
like you know free food all day bro i'm
like [ __ ] let's go so i started working
there for you know
a few months yeah when i was 18 i stayed
in japan for much longer than one month
actually uh probably like four months
yep the first two months i was there on
my work there and then i started taking
night shifts because my you know taint
show wanted me to make drinks and serve
it to the customers at the counter cool
and he said it was like a pizza place
that served alcohol exactly right right
right and then the main customers that
come in the evening were um
milfs let's say
so um he was like yo john um so he's
like a ex-sports teacher
you know he still has good ties with the
school and all of his like you know like
ex-students i'm he's still in contact
with are now all adults yeah and most of
the females are like married they have
kids they're like 25. and you know when
you're 25 and you're married to a
30-year-old japanese guy and he's away a
lot and you know maybe he's like an
erectile dysfunction
you kind of want to she kind of wants to
go talk to other people right okay i was
going to say we [ __ ] at the pizzeria
yeah
yeah
what's going on give me some context
about like what you're describing
literally sounds like the start of a
porn
that's gonna happen a lot throughout
this episode
i mean one thing that we should probably
mention is that uh cheating culture in
japan is pretty prevalent
it's [ __ ] it's it's very normal yeah
yeah nuts bro yeah that's crazy yeah so
i started working at this piece of place
um taking a nice show it's making drinks
for these ladies
chatting with them and i realized
they're coming back specifically to chat
with me that's what the boss is telling
me they're like yo
you know these ladies they want to hang
out with you after dangerously feeding
an 18 year old yeah yeah yeah and then i
i realized that they're allowed to buy
drinks for me while you know i'm making
drinks for them so i'm like the [ __ ] got
a pizza
where did we get the drinks from i
thought
i thought i had the image of like the
domino's counter yeah you were just
taking it i don't think this is a pizza
place i think this is a bar that serves
pizza well it's like a really high-end
pizza place that has a really really
sexy counter with like you know a lot of
high-end alcohol kind of lined up right
okay and then there's a nice you know
stool that people can sit on and then
drink on one one with the bartender
right right right soul ball
well with pizza attached to yeah yeah so
it's a bar that serves pizza it's not a
pizza place yeah again
really so when the wife goes there she
can be like no no no i'm not going to a
bar i'm gonna
so after after like a month or so
working there you know in the night
shift i realized that you know
i may be good at this
right right my boss was like and he's
such a nice guy bro you know
of course of course because i go hang
out with him still read his house and
[ __ ] so he told me you know
you talk because i was telling him
talking to about being becoming a hostel
like initially but i told him you know
like i don't want my parents down okay
so why did you want to be a host
initially before you entered easy money
man easy money bro guys like think about
it there's a job where you literally get
paid money to
drink with girls and just chat with them
when i do my video the money i saw that
they were getting paid was insane yeah
it's nice yeah it was it was like some
of them could make like fifty thousand
dollars a night yeah easy if you if it's
just why are we youtubers
they [ __ ] left at me when they were
like how much do you make and i told
them how much i made like the year
before yeah
and they were like that's how much you
made they all
just write off whatever the [ __ ] it's
crazy bro so okay so what was the
process of like getting into your first
hosting job then okay so after the piece
of stuff i decided to apply right yeah
um you can apply like like you do you
just talk to someone or do you have like
a job
yeah so you go on the [ __ ] internet
guys holy [ __ ]
so you just type in you know
you just break this right
you just find the nearest one so i went
to the one in ikebukuro because that was
like five minutes train away from where
i was living at the time yeah
i'm not sure if that was like attention
that was a tension
building up the tension this is like his
host his host coming out yeah he's
drinking a gin and tonic by the way oh
yeah guys it's like two in the afternoon
we we we want a drink but we can't we
have our health check yeah we have a
health channel let me go over just like
real quick i have to get out of myself
okay so people listen to me okay we've
been discussing about you know this
podcast day for like a year you know
since we met we were trying to get janna
for a while now yeah and then i was
always like you know we're gonna get
[ __ ] smashed when i show up right are
you guys [ __ ] ready and last week um
i had to cancel because some [ __ ]
happened and then you know i said about
next week what is it yeah let's do it
yeah and i show up today with this
bottle
and the first thing they say they're
like
we can't drink today though
damn i'm sorry to be fair john we have
been asking you for a whole year yeah 52
weeks which is not this week yeah to say
yes
so so that's that's a valid enough
excuse to not let me know that you can't
drink this week we didn't think about it
but we didn't think about it we actually
i actually completely forgot i had a
health checkup until this morning i came
out yeah yeah yeah i was like oh yeah
that's tomorrow [ __ ]
i i have nurses i mean it's okay we'll
drink when uh the cameras are off uh
when it's not today yeah it's just like
we're like we always do yeah like we all
like like we've
yeah no it doesn't work that way bro you
know because something i want to go
around camping everyone individually i'm
like cheers cheers i mean jan does all
right
he's a host though yeah
this episode is sponsored by expressvpn
using the internet without using
expressvpn is like leaving your keys in
the car while you run to the gas station
for a snack most of the time you're
probably fine but what if you come back
to see someone driving off with your car
every time you connect to an unencrypted
network cafes hotels airports any hacker
on the same network can gain access to
your personal data passwords financial
details etc and it really doesn't take
much technical knowledge to hack someone
just some cheap hardware is needed even
joey could do it without his graphics
card
your data is valuable and hackers can
make up to one thousand dollars per
person selling personal information on
the dark web but guys why use expressvpn
well let me tell you it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet hackers can't steal your
sensitive data at all it would take joey
over a billion years to try and hack
into your computer and a billion more of
you at expressvpn plus it works on all
your devices phones laptops tablets and
more so you can stay secure on the go
and everyone who watches transportation
areas that i use expressvpn it's easy
it's very easy to use it's genuinely
yeah [ __ ] it up you can change the
country it's super easy i i just use it
it's painless even i can use it so
secure your data today by visiting
expressvpn.com trash taste that's e x p
r e s s v p n dot com slash trash taste
and you can get an extra three free
months that's expressvpn.com slash trash
taste links in the description below
actually all right so yeah tell us how
you got into this at least
so you looked up host club tokyo and
then you applied for one in nicaragua
uh-huh and then you just walked in um
yeah basically is that easy well they
have an interview okay and they actually
pay you to go to the interview can you
believe that is that new or is that like
yeah so has it always been like um this
is where the you know difference in
clubs come in so for example if you go
to a you know very well-known club in
um if you know that's like one of the
[ __ ] most prestigious i know the name
yeah yeah so they're not gonna pay you
to go there you know you're gonna go
there you're gonna do the interview and
they're gonna tell you to [ __ ] off like
90 of the time yeah yeah but smaller
clubs and you know but [ __ ] nowhere like
ikebukuro kind of
they are lacking staff so they need more
hosts to actually fill the you know
place right um so they actually pay
people to take the interviews because
they can afford it wait so they pay you
even if you don't get in yeah exactly
they pay you for your time bro wow so
actually the first oh yeah so is the
host industry that big that we have like
a shortage of like employees in the host
industry um i mean there is a shitload
of host clubs and justin toca yeah so i
mean i guess the demand is there yeah
wow okay i guess i guess it's not really
like apparent maybe yeah just look at it
from a surface of like just how much in
demand it is i think back in the day at
least for girls bars i read that they
would literally just like hire tourists
really no they weren't oh they're not
allowed to obviously yeah of course like
they would hire foreign girls for girls
bars that would work on tourist visas
they would just you could just like
girls would just walk into bars i can
believe that yeah i want to work here
yeah okay yeah sure wow i met a girl
like that the other day actually
dude
near a girls bar next to my house um
that i always go to just to check out
like who's new and stuff
there was this russian girl
who's here for like exchange yeah you
know she's only she for like four yeah
yeah supposed to be working yeah yeah
exactly
yeah exactly no it's nothing legal but
she's still there i'm sure that's not
the dodgiest thing you've seen but we'll
get into it we'll get into some of the
other stories later if you join this you
know you get paid for the interview yeah
so i hope two places and then at that
time i was thinking like
how about i hop like 50 places and not
join any of them
because when you said that they would
pay you and not even join i'm just like
i'm just like there's an idea exactly
what if i just apply to jobs and not
join how does this interview process go
then do they you just make make you
drink like so you go you fill in like a
basic sheet that's kind of the
employment thing your name your address
and whatnot um and then they ask you
questions just to chat with you you know
have you ever done this before am i good
at socializing can you handle drinks how
does it not work before i can't actually
but yeah um i was gonna
originally do like a hopping thing just
to collect like and they pay a lot they
pay like four thousand somewhat to pay
six thousand so it's four justices yeah
yeah just to go to an interview which
finishes like an hour bro i know right
crazy so
so how many hours is that on the
pizzeria
it's like
six hours like a single interview yeah
that place was not about money it's
about like the friends we made along the
way
[Laughter]
oh my god
there's 47 by the way
[Laughter]
anyway yeah so so you decided to join
the ikebukuro oh yeah so after two
interviews i decided you know what i
kind of like this place
um so it was a really interesting one
because until that point they never
really made me sit with an actual
customer all right but for the ikebukuro
place that i went to um it was called
asset um that place literally made me
sit down with a customer and just drink
with them like straight up right so it
wasn't even like it was like trial by
fire it was just around an actual
customer that was there yeah exactly
exactly but it was like one of the close
you know um customers of one of like the
members there right right you know he
the shocho asked him like is it okay if
we have like this random ass guy just
chat with her for a bit just to see if
he's capable yeah and you know she said
[ __ ] yeah so i sat down drank [ __ ]
bigger bombs with her
[ __ ] love was that her choice
my choice bro oh my god it's gross of
course you of course you're 18 at the
time that makes so much sense
put it in my veins
so we drank um jaeger bombs and cocaro
you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah she's crazy the
green one right that uh like
it's it's got like some substance in it
that's like
it's like chlorine i think is actually
in the [ __ ] in the alcohol yeah actually
something like that yeah it's awful for
your heart yeah i yeah i'm not surprised
bro
i think i i served it in the the gay bar
video i did it's yeah right it's a green
it's like a green one yeah a red bull at
the bottom then it's just like red bull
with cochlear or jesus red bull on the
bottom and then it sounds [ __ ] and
then it's the the 40 spirit on top and
like they're not supposed to mix yeah so
the idea is that it's like this
presentation that's like fancy and stuff
bloody hell it's [ __ ] i think you can i
think you pull someone out of a coma
with them yeah generally like just like
just dude you should like let's just
christen people with that the [ __ ]
baby will stop
the babe will stop floating yeah
uh sorry go ahead yeah yeah so you sat
down with this lady oh yeah just like
trying to try it out yeah so that was
your first time yeah first i remember
did you kill it did you get one was it
awkward yeah no not at all man was
drinking with her um you know like why
did you come here well i'm trying it out
i'm a student blah blah blah oh she was
just like she was interviewing you she
maybe she was the real person that was
the real interviewer this is like some
undercover boss yeah i'm actually the
owner of this yeah
the thing is i'll get into this a bit
more later but like you know
in like the traditional way of doing
hostile you're supposed to have the
other person talk the most yeah and
that's with any sales tactic right if
you come out of an interview in general
talking more than the other person that
means you have to do the selling right
yeah if you make the other person talk
more that means you know they're trying
to do something to impress you or
they're just having a good time that
they just want to talk more
but
in this case you were just asking me
questions like where are you from why do
you have a [ __ ] beard how are you 18
holy [ __ ] 35 you know stuff like that
yeah
stuff and like the more i i answer stuff
it intrigued her more to ask more
questions so you know at the end she
said you know i want to see this guy
again i'm going to [ __ ] hire him i
was like let's go start tomorrow right
right i can make it sound so simple just
uh just ask questions bro yeah i mean
you guys probably know but you could
become a hostel tomorrow bro why me
because you speak japanese
it doesn't mean i'm good at socializing
not that i have any plans to be a host
sorry guys i'm not going to well we have
a plan don't you think yeah i want to do
like a version two of it what do you
mean the host club video
video all right all right yeah did you
go chat now it's like show you around
exactly yeah good in the video yeah bro
i want to take you to you know my homies
place
show you around when jan says homie's
place it's like i just think it like the
most sketch [ __ ] yeah
i don't know why i have like my my
preconceptions of host clubs and and
whatnot just because from filming my
video where i went to host club yeah and
i got to see everything there you know
and obviously we cut a lot of stuff that
i couldn't show but yeah you know one
misconception i had about host clubs is
that i thought you had to be like
[ __ ] like literally looking like a
rock star like sexy as [ __ ]
it's like you literally just have to
have a like a gimmick right almost yeah
and this guy's gimmick was that he was
an [ __ ]
that was like his character right mainly
was that yeah so i think like was what
was it and who's kind of
who's you know he was a bit larger yeah
yeah yeah but he was just big
oh he calls himself a pig and also i am
very grateful they let me film i mean
they they really did like give me like
all access and like it's tough to get
permission
they're really nice about it like did
you have to like hook them up and stuff
no
no i don't we didn't do anything did we
no no
no nothing we literally just shouted out
his youtube i think that was it yeah it
was it was one of the situations where
that's kind of dope i didn't really know
what was going on i don't think any of
us really knew what was happening right
we just kind of got dragged in and we
were doing it and i didn't know if i was
going to pay for stuff yeah yeah yeah
but like you know he was i from what i
was gathering like he was being rude
like it was partially a character but i
think there was partially some of it
that might have been
how he has to stem from somewhere right
you know i he was trying to be funny
yeah as well like he was trying to crack
jokes yeah at my expense which i didn't
mind i you know i can i can take that
yeah i'm not uh
yeah i i don't know i i you know i mean
maybe you know sometimes when when you
bring cameras into a place like that
sometimes people feel like they wanna
you know one-off show off yeah yeah do i
seem like that to you right now no no no
no
i know that you [ __ ] up
but uh you're more of an [ __ ] off
camera yeah
that is not the case
that is not the case
but yeah it was it was interesting i
what shocked me the most was how like
transparent it all was like the hosts
were like very
transparent with about that they were
like we don't care but but they they do
this whole act that they do care yeah
but it's so obvious that they don't and
and they they almost tell them that they
don't care in many ways it's really part
of the customers yeah it's really
strange and um that's that's where we go
into the whole psychology of it and then
the tactics they employ to actually you
know garner these
it's something i don't think i can quite
it's
if you're not from japan it would take
years for you to wrap your head around
because you have to feel like you need
to understand
what led up to this as a culture
yeah yeah yeah yeah
so so like as a host what is the big
appeal of host clubs you know
from from the others yeah why do so many
girls in japan
love going to host clubs and like not
just going but like spending like
gangsters
yeah
very good question so this has kind of a
lot of sides to it but um the main you
know answer i would say is just the
social structure of japan itself right
as you also mentioned
japan is not really like
a social friendly place
especially when you look at the type of
people that actually go to the host
clubs
so again a huge tangent but the reason
why i wanted to go to host club or one
of the reasons is to see what kind of
people actually work there yeah what
kind of people actually go there because
it made no sense like why would i spend
money to chat with guys yeah i can just
go to you know bar and pay to drink with
a guy right that's a girl yeah so
um once i entered that was like the main
thing that i looked into what kind of
people go there why do they go there and
what kind of people actually work there
so what i figured out is
most of the customers that we would get
and i'm sure it's the same across the
board
there are also people who work in the
nightlife
yeah
most of the people like easy i would say
more than 80 percent of the people that
we got they were always you know like
whatever some kind of a nightlife where
your pride your dignity it's [ __ ]
stepped on all day long and it's
you know you're out of your job the one
thing you want is being pampered one
thing you want is feeling like you're
being respected one thing even if it's
artificial as [ __ ] yeah you know it you
want to feel this guy giving you this
utter
you know sense of service and then you
know
do anything for you kind of thing yeah
yeah yeah quite a depressing aspect of
japanese culture yeah if you put it in
that perspective yeah but it has its own
culture within itself where you know
once you go a lot to a host club for
example like you get to meet the chacho
charcoal
you know like all like owners basically
and they're not like you know randomized
people they're usually very wealthy
japanese businessmen yeah and if you're
in the nightlife and then you get to
hang out with the chacho you know he
might elevate you in some way or another
maybe he might put you in a different
you know like a kabakra or something you
know so there's actually different up
the reasons as to why you would go to a
host club depends on the person all
right so how often would you get like
you know like a newbie come to the host
club like you know someone who's first
time ever yeah you know someone who's
like saying not part of like the
industry or that kind of environment
someone just like someone is just like
curious to be like oh i want to see what
a host club is yeah
actually when you start off that's your
main goal um you go outside the club you
go nampa on the street with random girls
and you let them know what's number one
yeah you just hit on them
bro you're like a 2010 youtuber
so you know the thing was you just go up
to them be like hey i work right there
you know i would love to drink with you
it's a thousand six hundred yen per hour
on my whole day right what are the what
like what's the success rate of this
one in 100 will be generous yeah right
so well they'll do it just because they
feel sorry for you
bro it's japan bro people value their
time and money yeah yeah yeah i'm
privacy
exactly exactly no one appreciates some
random dude getting this close and being
linked you know no one's gonna be like
yeah let's do it you know yeah cause i
see it all the time when you go to like
shibuya and shinjuku of like these dudes
who clearly work at host clubs yeah
going up to these girls and these girls
just don't even don't even give them
like any attention they're used to it
bro japanese girls that go to these
places they know that some catchy guy is
going to come to you yeah just you know
walk straight ahead yeah yeah it's kind
of the same with like you know made
cafes but just like up the opposite way
around yeah you said like you go to
akihabara or you know
kabukicho and you like see a lot of
maids on the streets trying to get
people to come in their maid cafes as
well you just like don't even give them
periphery at all
just like don't make eye contact don't
make it like the moment they realize in
the periphery they are there they'll
just come up to you and like give you a
pamphlet right yeah
it sucks
so like so was that what you had to do
as you when you joined the host club was
that like your first jobs uh yeah
initially that was my first ever proper
job after the you know pizza bar but
yeah
so for the first you know couple of
months
well not even like first year because
you know i wasn't living in japan
so for the first time i was there and
then second year that i was there
you're going at 5 00 p.m
clean the [ __ ] place with your other
homies that are not selling
right yeah so you just make everything
pristine as [ __ ] and then your senpais
would come in and be like what's the
[ __ ] dirt there bro
height
that thing but i love that about you
fanny i mean but you know it's fun
because i still make banter out of it
you know yeah like no one would go up to
their senpai and build how about you do
it [ __ ] but like i would do it you know
like
his stuff and be like you know number
one you think you're this hot [ __ ] [ __ ]
come you clean it i'm not doing it [ __ ]
you and he'll be like yo i like you
yeah absolutely and it's the same with
the way you approach the customers
because
the number one rule they tell you when
you join is do not ask them personal
questions don't ask them what they do
your their real name their address you
know how they make their living it's so
hard because i remember when i did it i
was like [ __ ] this like when you meet
someone all you do is like just ask them
like
hey yeah exactly
and combined with the fact that i'm also
you know used to that but also my main
purpose was to do a survey as to you
know why the [ __ ] do people come to
these places anyway yeah so you know i
was like crack okay first girl i ever go
into you know what why why are you here
why are you here yeah right here
and my senpai's are just like what the
[ __ ]
the girl's like well that's what worked
in my favor because i was acting like i
was your gimmick
well the main purpose also
was to get information but again
i was playing this character where i'm
that gaijin guy who has no idea what the
[ __ ] he's doing but you know it's that
friendly neighborhood gaijin doing his
best right that character gathering so
was that like a character you like made
up or was that something you were just
like okay i i i know this is the
character i'm gonna play and i'm gonna
play actually really because i never
gave a [ __ ] what they told me to do
because i was like bro you fire me today
i'll go to the next place you know
they pay me money to go to the
interviews like i give a care you know
right right
so you know you figured out the system
man yeah the system oh it's just all
about not giving a [ __ ] host hate this
one trick
click to find out
so you know employing this tactic of
just asking these girls like what do you
do
my main structure of conversation was
literally just being a life coach to
these girls
but
just bitcoin nft
invest
just to go over like the general
structure so i think last time i went
over you know how i got chosen and [ __ ]
so you know you clean the stuff you
start sitting down with girls and then
when there's a new girl that comes in
who's never been to that club before
what you do is each guy gets to sit down
with her for five minutes yeah just five
minutes
you give your card you compliment them
you talk them
and then after five minutes they switch
around i i love that host clubs have
business card i host hosts have business
cards yeah i sure have brought mine
today bro it's really sick it's like
some stock trading stuff let me bring it
out is it just like that scene from like
american psycho oh let me see your
business card fine nice print
like so you had five minutes to prove
yourself yeah exactly so you do that you
rotate and after the first 45 or 50
minutes i choose someone right yeah they
actually stand out in five minutes yeah
well see that's the thing bro most
people just you know go like oh your
eyes are beautiful
why are you here why don't you go
somewhere else
hang out with your friends and she's
like what do you mean
and i'm like oh my god i love him
well you're spending money to drink with
me that means you know there's a reason
why you're here why are you here
and then like i make them explain like
justify their their reason for being
there right so like i clearly don't get
along with close-minded people or people
who are not willing to chat bro you
would get ladies that would just come in
and open their phones and just you know
scroll through and i see that for like a
minute and i'm like yeah no
[ __ ] change right right i'm not gonna
sit with you to be fair that is a that
is a waste of money like but it's what's
in my head it's a waste of the host of
the host clubs they offer uh unlimited
drinks yeah exactly for the first 60
minutes you're in there right
um and it's normally considerably
cheaper yeah it's it's [ __ ] cheap
it's like it's like one thousand yen for
like all you can drink yeah so i guess i
guess ghost has come into just yeah
because the next drink if you buy one
beer it's like it's like 30 bucks yeah
yeah
everything's like 10 times the [ __ ]
market price yeah i mean it's like that
with a lot of like even girls bars as
well that's how you they get you in
right they get you in for the all you
can drink and then
and then they sell you on other stuff
right yeah yeah yeah luckily i think
guys are a bit easier to convince to
stay in the bar then
they're [ __ ] girls yeah
one thing i've always been curious about
is like how cutthroat is it how
cutthroat is this industry
honestly again this comes down to what
kind of club you work at um the place i
was at you know it's like [ __ ] teddy
bears and sugar daddies you're coming on
trash and you're cleaning yourself for
us
i feel i feel bad you know i've done a
lot of the host clubs i don't know if
you all said this but they they rank all
the staff right oh yeah they were so
some anime [ __ ] like well they have to
because at the entrance um so at my peak
i was number three out of 20 people that
were working there nice um yeah [ __ ] it
that's right that's right
we've got power rankings yeah but can
you be goku
go you know goku was
at the entrance of the club you usually
have like a little poster that says who
has the most amount of shime which is
girls that come in and choose you as as
like their daddy basically all right
every day come in they want to see with
you
right you have to use the word daddy
what's the equivalent in english
like honey
i don't know daddy the shirt
oh it gives you money
yeah exactly what
you're asking the wrong person yeah
you're right okay
yeah daddy anyway
um
so yeah you they display that because as
i mentioned the value of your host club
is also elevated by what kind of person
you have there so some clubs they have
this one host who's like the industry
head like top right if he moves it's
like a good example would be league of
legends professional scene now you're
talking
so for example if double lifts change
teams
who's going to follow him the fans and
in league of legends professional scene
the fans make up the entirety merge you
know like the filling the stage
generally all the hype of the
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's the same
with host clubs so people aren't loyal
to the host club they're hoyle their
their lawyers
depends some host clubs have a huge
history like
yeah they're known to be a [ __ ] you
know strat industry standard
in terms of being like a really high-end
club with you know spectacular service
and having the best hosts but there are
some you know newbie clubs that are
elevated by perhaps recruiting these
guys who work at these prestigious clubs
and raise their name value so so it's
literally so it is it's literally like
they're trying to like poach the best
players yeah
for sure man i guess and all this anime
ranking system which is based off the
host this comes with the host industry
it's it's strange you know in japan how
in some ways they don't like the work
culture is so like against ranking
anyone against each other but there's
certain industries where it's like
you're ranked against everyone if you
fail you are [ __ ] eliminated i mean
japanese schools do that [ __ ] yeah
that's strange yeah like like an
end-of-year exam and like two weeks
later when they finish marking it
there's huge [ __ ] it's not all
scripts but most schools have these huge
[ __ ] posters saying like here's the
top 100 placements i just realized
[ __ ] host club just sounds like
ranked elo yeah
technically
yeah exactly technically you're [ __ ]
right but then like the dichotomy is
that they have lifetime contracts right
workers can't be fired from companies
yeah yeah it's just so weird like pick
one it's like okay so i so i'm not gonna
get fired from my job just because i'm a
low ranking you just literally did it to
make me feel like [ __ ]
like that's the only
reason so you were number three out of
all this thing for a time being all
right damn that's crazy
how fast how how fast did it take you to
get to number three years bro like yes i
assume that's difficult right
you have to build your clientele right
like as i mentioned the tactic that i
was employing it's not really customer
friendly
you know most japanese ladies are not
used to some gaijin with a beard coming
up to them be like why are you here why
are you paying money to see guys you can
just go to a club yeah or anywhere yeah
so the people that actually stuck around
to drink with me they're like
open-minded people they wanted to mostly
hear about my experiences in life you
know living abroad experiencing going to
a bunch of countries having [ __ ] up
parties and stuff you don't be asking
what is the normal clientele demographic
so it really changes man so most people
might imagine it's like obachans you
know like yeah you know old ladies with
like
rich husbands yeah but
to your surprise
you actually get like you know early 20s
like idols and stuff sometimes
i mean i guess that kind of makes sense
right because in what environment can an
idol just go out and just be comfortable
right in a normal environment yeah maybe
maybe not like the super popular ones
but like especially like all the
underground idols like yeah yeah and
there's a shitload yeah there's a
shitload of them bro they don't really
have like a an image to keep i guess
yeah as as strong as like say like 8k 48
or something right yeah they can go to a
host club
because because you know as someone who
grew up you know abroad from japan do
you think the host environment can work
in like any other country or is it just
like something that's only in japan
only because of the social media you do
that in turkey
look you you'll have a [ __ ] like
army of taxi drivers ready to beat you
up
like literally my taxi driver bro cause
they're like they're like the mafia of
turkey
dude in turkey they say don't [ __ ] with
bus drivers like taxi drivers because
they're all like a you know gang
[ __ ] with one of them you you call up
the entire neighborhood
why dude like
this is real though this is huge because
i don't know if i told you guys but like
in the past three years when i go back
to turkey yeah i always find this one
taxi guy who can like quote unquote for
me around but that's because turkish
currency is [ __ ] right now so you know i
can take cabs anywhere yeah but once
you're really good with the taxi guy and
you know treat him like your own
personal driver
and you get to experience what kind of
life he lives man wherever district you
go to he calls somebody up and says you
know what's the next target do you have
any customers around here
let me let me redirect these people to
your way bro they worked like a hive
mind bro it's crazy they just sound like
a bunch of like organized assassins
they're they're insane they've all got
backers and so
like whenever you get into trouble you
call one of them like my main homie and
then he will call this homie's homie and
then in 10 minutes you will have like 30
[ __ ] guys ready for you
i [ __ ] you're not
that's the benefit of being is going on
in turkey bro it's all about connections
people you meet why taxi drivers because
they're amazing bro because they get
everywhere i mean yeah they know
everybody bro cause who talks to
customers the most barbers and taxi
drivers yeah not in japan because they
suck here but in turkey like you get on
first thing they say is like what's your
religion why are you here
the cia i sleep yeah taxi drivers that's
the real [ __ ]
honestly honesty honestly people don't
know about this it's [ __ ] nice
john snowden just moved to turkey and
like all right and now i'm impressed
[Laughter]
oh my god
sorry i've forgotten completely where
we've got laughter that was like one of
the
we're talking about before with uh taxi
drivers um what are like some of the
most interesting clients all that you've
had yeah what are the interesting drives
before
yeah oh yeah
we're talking about demographics and
[ __ ] yeah yeah so you said you had like
really really like young girls like in
like early 20s yeah you know like people
the audience would kill to drink with
you know
eyes opponent
don't mean to
was the owner of a um apparel brand
right he knew a lot of models and stuff
oh okay yeah so he was really well
versed in the whole you know so he
invited the models to like yeah he would
invite his like people he works with who
he works with to the club and then you
know we would have a jolly good time
together
who who were like some of the most like
i guess memorable ones you had
because i'm sure you've met like a a
wide array of like different characters
yeah yeah yeah well honestly the young
girls um not really memorable because at
the end of the day if you lived in japan
your whole life i never left the
country with the lack of life experience
there's not much i can gain out of you
it's mostly me talking about myself and
like you know is the party like that
blah blah blah but it gets old after a
while right so the best client that i
ever had and i still still do see
sometimes to this day
is a very you know senior lady
who is just there for
you know gaining more friends in life
someone who's like above 60
she she doesn't need to do anything you
know she's like sure for you know
bentley she comes to the place you know
sure for chafford manor yeah comes in
spends money leaves
but the stories she has
is something yeah you know spending time
with her is you know
that's when i feel like i'm actually
doing something right
so that's what you enjoy about
being host i guess is hearing
interesting stories hearing about life
experience yeah exactly i mean it gets
boring after a while you know just
talking about yourself oh what the [ __ ]
a lot of things just fell there yeah so
maybe i jinxed something
i'm sorry my patreon
i guess it makes sense right because
there's only so many times where you can
tell your life story and get the same
old it's the goal over and over again
right yeah
i i get that yeah
you know that would get boring what do
you think like makes a like a successful
host then
is it the gimmick do you need like a
unique gimmick to be like a successful
host well looks definitely don't mean
[ __ ] in the crowd
which is weird because you'd think that
that would mean something right
a lot of comments on my youtube video
were like well some of these guys aren't
beautiful it's like yeah it doesn't have
to be that has like a surface level
value to it like first impressions
impressions yeah but after that it's all
about your demeanor the way you [ __ ]
carry yourself forward how you present
yourself
and most people
employ what i guess what i just told you
guys about which is don't talk about
personal stuff yeah compliment them
beautiful eyes whatever
and then try to get them to like you in
that way everybody has their own shtick
yeah to a certain degree so you'd say
like personality is way more important
yeah 100 percent yeah like in real life
yeah like in real life real life holy
[ __ ] honestly this is what where i want
to mention my you know most respected
hostel related person which is dora
under sound he's like top of the top so
he's not even a hostel anymore no not
anymore yeah he was he was i explained
what roland is to the audience so to
those that don't know um please this is
rorando check him out but
to those who don't know rorando started
off as a hosto in his early twenties
[Laughter]
you gotta like plan out things like man
like do it when someone else is talking
or something you know
you do realize there are people who
listen audio only right so it's just
like a long pause okay well then you
feel the gap for me
yeah when you do it so like out of
nowhere i was like
oh [ __ ]
okay yeah so roland right yeah so he
started as a normal host and he climbed
his way through he went to prachanda and
then he went his own club called
basically man this guy
proved to the world that hosto is not
something that only dumbasses who fail
at life do
it's
what shrewd businessman can do to
leverage their position because he's
like super smart right bro he's he's you
know he's i mean not just like straight
small but he's also like actually
exactly right but the fact that he
always keeps his own host of values
which is how arrogant he is the way he
brings himself forward like he always
knows and shows that he's the best
looking and the smartest guy in the room
right right you know in japanese culture
it's always about like i don't
you know like
being below the other person being
humble right exactly but
he takes this and then flips on them
and then basically like mounts on you
right and like these poor japanese
businessmen they're just like oh my god
they don't know how to handle it i mean
so basically he's a chad yeah he's like
he's a [ __ ] chef it's like a giga
chat yeah i'm surprised you guys didn't
like collab or do anything with him yet
you know
why would he give a [ __ ] yeah why would
he give a [ __ ] i don't know
well the thing is you know um
diversifying into the foreign market i
mean i i'd like to do something with him
because i've known about him for such a
long time because at one point
especially when he
had just come out of the host business
and like started his own company exactly
like that like he was everywhere on
japanese tv like he was like he's
probably like i would say on in the
grander scale of japanese like
entertainment he's probably the most
well-known host ever absolutely yeah
absolutely so like it was just really
interesting because i i read up on him
as well because i was like who's this
[ __ ] rolling guy yeah and i read up
on him and he's like yeah like you can
tell this guy is just like so [ __ ]
street smart when it comes to like
business and stuff like that and like he
clearly knows his way on making himself
well you got to be street smart to be a
[ __ ] host right but like i think as
as jan said it completely flipped
society's impressions of what hosts can
be right yeah right because it's yeah as
you said like to everyone hosts were
just like good-looking dudes who have
nowhere to go and just want to like talk
about the jokes for money yeah yeah but
like i think roland completely flipped
that everyone was like no you don't have
to be like that to be a successful host
if anything
doing that doesn't make you successful
exactly and
the most like impressive thing about
roland is the way he approaches you know
his customers
as i mentioned my main impression is
through him well i discovered him after
i became a host to be honest with you
but then i discovered the way i do
things similar to him which is
be arrogant
be arrogant about yourself because i
know for a fact that within the entire
district of ikebukuro i have more like
life experience
than anybody that you can meet there
yeah but with that as a leverage what i
try to do is
you know levitate the other person
you know i want the the customer to
leave my presence with a feeling of you
know rejuvenation something like
like like the ones you're using i don't
know
you just you say it as if they came out
of a baptism
well it's not like you're saying a
religion yeah i'm a new man where do you
think uh you know life experience comes
from where do you think you learn life
experience
but in general where do you think it
comes from well just
tackling new activities in different
places with people we have never met
before
like if you stayed in japan your whole
life never left the [ __ ] you know
neighborhood
versus someone who's traveled the world
especially like if you live in the
you know vicinity of europe
yeah you can't just go to like 20
different countries yeah yeah yeah like
easily that's the good thing about
europe yeah exactly for me because like
to me the concept of driving to another
country is so boy because like japan you
can't do that australia you sure you
should do that i can't even drive to the
next state
right so it's like it's so cool to think
that
in such a small space there are so many
cultures right so i've always been
jealous of like especially you guys like
like the fact that you guys lived in the
uk and like you know didn't explore all
of europe it was like a lot of europe
yeah yeah what's your favorite european
but i feel that's the way to do it
though austria austria austria's like
chill germany
[Music]
i'm sure the germans will be thrilled to
hear that
german germans know they love their
rules
got like everything that germany has
yeah but it's like
where's your favorite that's not turkey
oh man czech republic oh yeah okay
i've heard you're saying
yeah rubbing your foot against your legs
that's all good man
he's getting into it
bro
though man like it's middle of europe
germany like berlin is like five hour
bus away so you can you know technical
clubs whatever in the uk right people
are just obsessed with getting cheap
holidays mm-hmm yeah so
so i ended up going to like really odd
places that you would like never go to
for any normal reason because someone
was like we're having a wedding there
like i went to malta i was probably like
the four malta viewers who are watching
this
[Applause]
cheap holiday right
it's like it's a really cool place yeah
it is why would you like yeah
you go to a travel agent sometimes in
england and they just they just like
they're they're certainly like we have a
country yeah
there's a good deal going on in this
country right now yeah
i think that's the best though right
area cyprus because those aren't
countries that
fake turkey
well cyprus's history is like half half
greek it's half germany
there's some beef going down there
attack you guys yeah we should probably
cut that one out no that's fine they'll
understand i understand we [ __ ] on
countries all the time okay that's your
beef right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're the one that said not us well i'm
turkish that's why you're turkish so
it's it's all good you have horses in
this race if i say it it's just like so
just look forward to a lot of people
from cyprus coming into your chat to
just remind you of what you come to my
twitch stream just to [ __ ] on me
guys let's go
no but like that's the thing right it's
like i that's what i like about europe
though is because there's like the
countries that everyone knows that
everyone wants to go to italy france
spain you know the ones that you think
of when you think europe yeah but then
you realize that there are so much more
and even these tiny countries there's so
much like unique culture yeah just
within that so it's like for me it's
like i want to try and go to as much of
europe as i possibly can problem is my
entire life it's been on the other side
of the [ __ ] world yeah it's it's like
the grass is greener on the green on the
other side right because for me i never
fully took advantage of that because i
was like so obsessed with exploring asia
i i just loved like exploring asian
countries that i just didn't realize
what the [ __ ] was in my backyard my
entire life yeah yeah yeah like my
parents fought like took me like i have
a choice but i probably wouldn't have
gone i would have definitely gone to
asia or america right right because like
for me i grew up and i'm just like oh
mom and dad are we going on holiday oh
is it is it thailand again oh we're
going to see grandma again for like the
uh so you know the the 20th time in my
life yeah for being like being 20 years
old so you know
yeah that was like holidays for me yeah
that makes sense yeah but like getting
back to what where where did we get to
the [ __ ] host thing i guess [ __ ] so
you were talking about the the
very rich 60 year old uh bougie oh yeah
man like and honestly like i don't know
if she will ever watch this but
what i really like about her is
how seductive she is and
in the way she just like conducts
herself like
i feel there was a better choice there
to be honest oh she is there
she would just ask me like hey john how
was your day but like the way she does
it yeah the way she moves her body the
way she has eye contact like she's just
it's like someone who's aware of every
single like muscle movement in their
body
you know and like i just watch her and
just like melt away you know i'm like
you know keep talking to me please and
that's true fair i guess six-year-old
japanese women look a lot younger than
six that is true sixty-year-old
six-year-old japanese women can look 30
or something she looks magnificent like
you would
you would barely think she's over 35.
she's turning on the host yeah
and she would always come in trippy
she's pretty eyes
she's beautiful she's actually beautiful
she's she's not going to tell her is
that what you tell her obviously i
always always tell her like you know but
clearly he actually feels that way yeah
yeah she brings it up you sound like
you're describing the love of your life
yeah what's going on no i just you know
like since she i also respect her a lot
because of her experiences in general
you know she has a lot to talk about but
also the fact that she's such a
self-aware person
who's able to make me feel the way i do
that's something you know it's stuff
like that that you know the idol girls
can't do you know yeah i speak to these
girls and i just feel like wow you're
[ __ ] stupid aren't you
[Laughter]
that's just the truth though sometimes
when you're speaking and
i mean you must have met some really
stupid girls if you're saying that
i don't mean it that way i didn't mean
that way that came out wrong that came
out
i'm talking no no no no no no no no no
no no let me explain
stupid i mean you've met a lot of stupid
people there yeah so like your level of
stupid must be like really really stupid
okay i've met all sorts of different
people i realize that came out very
wrong he saved it at a lab yeah yeah
yeah i'm not calling jan stupid i would
like to say we do not have our mans
right now yeah
this is not our moment oh guys
i'm in the corner over here i'm back
into it i'm literally backed into a
corner you know [ __ ] black hole spin
in the interstellar yeah
i pulled out
a night out with a bro and you're just
like you know what if if you're doing
this i'm sorry man i don't have your
back man sorry i'm going to the toilet
there are sometimes you're like yeah go
you back anything you do joey sometimes
just like i was getting ready to call my
you know taxi driver home yeah yeah
so please anything but the taxi driver i
rather you call the cia
so like okay so you were the third best
host like how much grinding did you need
to do how much grinding on the on the
ladder did you need to do man
i guess i guess i guess like what is
what constitutes as grinding in the host
see that's a good thing so i guess i can
go into like the downsides of being a
host at this point yeah okay um
tying it back down to why people even go
to the host club so the reason is
because you can only find a hostel in
the host club
right why because the guy is working in
the evening until morning sometimes he
sleeps he wakes up he does his daily
course chores and then he has to go to
work again and it's like 5 p.m yeah so
that's why the only time you can see a
hostel is you know at the club
but as like a you know successful hostel
who has a bunch of clients that they're
juggling you have to go to lunches you
have to go to their birthdays you have
to go to anniversaries or whatever the
sorts to disneyland and you have to
spend a lot of money on gifts right when
you go on a date with them absolutely
this is something you pay for everything
right
yeah during the day when you see them i
mean i don't do that because i never
went on a date with a girl during the
day
because i just didn't care
but number one guy that's the difference
between me and the number one guy
because that's what he did right he
would sleep like two hours and then he
would go on a date with a girl to
disneyland act like he's having fun buy
[ __ ] at the disney store
you know it's literally like school it's
like if you do extracurricular
activities you're going to be like place
time yeah but you have to same thing
because it's like a give and take right
yeah the more you invest in the girls
that you hang out with the more they
want to give back but you know that's
not what i was interested in i always
made my interest very clear from the
beginning which is
why the [ __ ] are you here
i'm just going to collect data first
this literally just sounds like persona
5.
you like bring a gift like the social
rank increases sometimes
[Music]
yeah it is it's like you go on a date if
you want the girl to fight alongside you
during the battle then you've got to be
nice to them in the real world right
this is just the exact same thing this
is a simulation persona 5 is a host
simulator
discovery of the same discovery of the
century
god damn
okay yeah cause like oh my god cause
like yeah when you said gift like giving
gifts and stuff like that and the host
has to give gifts i can't imagine how
many gifts you have to give considering
japan's gift giving culture is already
insane it's bash it crazy bro the number
one hostel he would tell me depending on
the month depending on how the stars
online and how many people have you know
anniversaries and [ __ ] yeah yeah he
might spend up to 70 percent of his
income
on just gifting [ __ ]
going to places doing [ __ ] right right
you know but i guess that's like an
investment for him for sorts right yeah
i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then when your
birthday comes and then you're calling
like 14 girls to your birthday and
they're all paying like
you know
dude
[Applause]
i saw like advertisements of like one
host that he made over a hundred
thousand dollars in one night from his
book easy bro
hundred thousand dollars from from gifts
or just from people coming you know
gifts
right
that they built for you that's when you
like you that that's a natural person
who wishes their birthday was two days
the one guy who's like can i have a
birthday month please
like i'll be great i've got 24 hours in
my birthday like i guess i'm all
sleeping tonight because that's like an
extra like [ __ ] 10k that i could be
earning yeah yeah right wonder what i'll
get
one thing i remember
be definitely being uh um definite
downside i'd say is that a lot of them
you know a lot of them seemed like they
had
uh developed uh an alcohol addiction of
sorts
because you're forced to drink
almost every day
all right through a lot of a lot yeah
yeah can we go over the the whole
drinking culture sure
let's do it yeah it seems like these
dudes
okay so i
one thing that i found really weird is
that they were all just talking to each
other and joking about how they had all
been like throwing up that morning
because they were like
right right and i was like how often do
you i don't i'm not sure if was in the
video so how often do you like get so
drunk that you thought he was like yeah
three four times a week
three four times a week that's just
throwing up from drinking that's insane
that's that's insane how much do you
have to drink on like a regular working
night
um
for me it was mostly just about how much
i i want yeah
so so are you allowed to so say if like
one of your clienteles like buys you a
drink
can you say no exactly so did you have
the money the way the structure within
the host club works is
if you're the one coming in with a
client already that you met
you sit at the table side like us right
and across from us you would have a hit
and helping person who would be the one
arranging the drinks pouring [ __ ] out of
this you know the peasantry workplace
stuff i haven't done in ages was he was
he a host himself or was it just yeah
they're they're all hostile they're all
hostile oh sorry but it was like
if you don't have a girl for yourself
then minus will help your bro kind of
thing right right right and your
specific job is to just drink so that
your homie doesn't have to drink so he
can persuade the girl to buy more drinks
so that you can drink kind of thing
right so he literally gets paid to drink
your drinks yeah exactly
yeah because you so i don't know we've
said this in the episode but like the
way that hosts make money is from them
buying drinks right yeah for sure and
food too bro so you get a cut of every
single drink or how how does it work um
well at the end of the night depending
on the payment but
usually you get 40 of the spent spent
spending at the grocery spending so if
you're 550 drink you might get like yeah
if the girls spend a thousand why did
you choose 15 people ten dollar drinks
you get four dollars you get four
dollars a thousand more realistic
numbers okay then you would be like four
hundred bucks that you'll make right
right just drinking with somebody man
why are you hiring her just hire like a
[ __ ] aussie in the back room just
like
going with how this story is gone i
wouldn't be a great host i'd be a great
host who helps his hobie finishes
so so so this guy this guy i would i
would basically be an extra liver for
you so so so this helper guy he will sit
at the table
while you you are while you're talking
and he'll drink your drink that this
girl was born for you he doesn't talk
right no of course he talks you have to
make good conversation because i was
doing that for two years bro what you
have to do is just make conversation but
like how do you not step on the other
guy's toes if it's his girl yeah it's
his goal well sometimes some treacherous
[ __ ] happens
backstabbing
examples of stories yeah of course
well
if you can mostly happen between me and
the number one guy of the place i worked
at because we were really close homies
yeah because number one guy was very
interesting man this guy he was a normal
salary man
in the architecture business earning a
you know good salary for world standard
until he was 27. and one day he said
[ __ ] this i'm just gonna become a host
literally like he just gave up
everything he said you know i don't care
about it anymore i'm just going to
become a host and he's [ __ ]
successful at it dude a genius he's very
smart very good looking feminine as [ __ ]
but that just
that's how it works that's just the way
it is but this guy for example what
we're talking about by the way
uh the drinks are inevitable
uh did they uh did you ever have like
because obviously you have the helper
and the main card yeah yeah yeah yeah
sure yeah so when this guy brings and
you know like there will be evenings
where the number one guy would invite
like seven eight different girls at the
same time yeah so he like we would have
liked to get pissed off see they can't
say anything what are the girls going to
say
you're so successful
the girls can say like um i'm buying you
drinks to give me more attention what he
says well
sucks for you other girls want me too
but they don't want it get the [ __ ] out
no because then they would they say
what they would do is they'd be like hey
uh if you want your turn you gotta buy
me the champagne thing yeah exactly you
want to stay
shopping is right there we're going to
pop it and i'll stand out it's literally
like some kind of like [ __ ] squid
game ass thing where like putting them
against each other yeah right but in the
essence of it it's really kind of like a
it's taking an advantage kind of thing
of course it's absolutely taking
advantage but but in the grand scheme of
things the girls are the ones who decide
to come come back to it yeah that's true
you're not i guess they're not helping
you you're not tying them down right
right right strange yeah i don't know i
don't know in some ways it yeah that's
one way to look at it but i'm sure this
it's way deeper than that right it's
yeah i feel like yeah i don't know it
depends on the person i guess right yeah
i mean it just feels like the host the
entire host culture and the entire host
world just works on like obviously
different social rules and different
social values i mean yes i mean none of
them would probably be in a host club if
that wasn't the case right
we're four guys talking about why women
might go to it right we don't understand
it as well as we think we do sure yeah
so i feel like you know i don't want to
come off as misogynistic or anything
i'm sure there's a lot more layers to it
that we don't understand i don't
understand the culture we're obviously
just talking from like a surface well i
i honestly just find it's fascinating
yeah did you say go over though like did
why why the demographic yeah yeah yeah
right but i'm sure i'm sure not all
girls like that though right i mean
like why they come back yeah i'm sure
there's a lot more to it yeah yeah you
know it's one of those things as well
and and i don't know i feel like as well
because
i guess misogyny in japan is like a
thing like a bit more than the west i'd
probably say i mean it's like i mean the
rules are structured around it right
like
well and the laws as well the the
interesting thing about that is um
so in any culture whether japanese or
whatever no girls are attracted towards
what's you know perceived as an alpha
right right someone who seems to be
someone who seems to dominate the
environment someone seems like they're
on top of things so the way the
horseshoe i think it's all in general
yeah so in terms of the hostile industry
in itself it's
made so that if it's a girl that you
know that you invited is coming over
everybody around you including the
chacho you know the owner of the
business will do everything in their
power to make you look like the rock
star of the business
right for the time being because they
understand that if they do that the
girls will be like oh my god you know
the guy i've chosen you know he [ __ ]
owns the place right right the little
owner of the [ __ ] bar is bending over
[ __ ] you know doing backflips just to
like please my homies right right i must
have chosen their white guy it's all an
act it's just all well it's not though
the thing is at least the way acted you
know yeah well okay well your act is
your act comes from some kind of basis
of you as a person yeah exactly i'm sure
all the other hosts do that right yeah
like like like how how much
how much are like the host have like a
genuine personality behind that
character and how much is just like
completely made up
you know that depends from person to
person right i'm sure you've seen both
cases right yeah of course of course
some of them will really try to play it
up yeah
and it's just not them at all yeah not
at all yeah but sometimes i mean you
know like piggy boy that
that you you went on a date with you
know like that guy bro you know
it was it was really bizarre because i i
didn't quite come across on the video
but
because obviously
it was cut in like five minutes like the
whole part yeah but he had this one uh
girl in that video who we blowed out uh
who was like obsessed with him right but
like he like didn't give her the time of
day like he barely gave any attention to
her yeah that's what she likes bro yeah
she was so weird watching it it was like
he literally couldn't give a [ __ ] and
she was like i'm gonna marry him and
he's like yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it was so it was so
strange wasn't it million like watching
this uh this guy
right right here
back up back your homie
like get your man
like obsessed this girl was about the
main host and he just like didn't give a
[ __ ] yeah and it was like
she bought she spent she bought me the
champagne because he was like oh i want
to i want to impress yeah just guys yeah
so she god knows how much she spent on
that champagne because the cheapest one
i saw was like 5k something dollars
how much he spent just to impress him
for like one second it didn't even seem
like he gave a [ __ ] right well from from
what like i'm hearing right now you know
like i'd say like the closest comparison
i think of in the west is you know
people maybe pay for like us like an
experience if they have like a really
weird fetish or something right and it
seems like in japan this is just like
the social fetish in a way where it's
just they're paying for like a certain
experience that you know that maybe
maybe they can't you know stay out in
normal life it was cool
why are you laughing it's really true
though
what's so funny about it
i'm just speaking facts right he just
realized that he worked for a social
fetish i think that's what he realized i
realized that i'm running my own fetish
too at the same time you know yeah yeah
it's an eco stroke right it's not like i
don't enjoy it you know no it's it yeah
yeah bro is there a bigger ego stroke
than being paid to like have people talk
like
yeah people pamper you
exactly but like
my general impression of it when i left
i was like
you know because you have all this
[ __ ] anime all around host club and
you hear about host clubs oh it's so
cool
you know you think this is kind of like
cool kind of like
you know when i left i was like [ __ ]
this is depressing as [ __ ] yeah i'd say
like
most of the
clients there
seemed like depressed right it was like
it was it was hot the hosts saw the
people
some
i just felt like they they would just
describe it like they had like nothing
else to do like it was i i don't know
for me
oh god i'm sure for some girls though
that is the case right and that's and i
think that's why they go to host clubs
just because that's the only place where
as you said like they've been [ __ ] on
the entire day yeah they just want
someone to make them feel good right you
have this [ __ ] club they got to deal
with me putting the camera in their
[ __ ] face i felt so bad
you being awkward as [ __ ] jesus christ
maybe they're only depressed in front of
the camera
that might have been here
like cool the one time i get privacy
this dude has a camera you disagree with
that or do you think it was it's all
like fun no i i agree with you bro
no because you know one thing that i
have to always remember is you know the
customers that i attract versus the
average joe is right
yeah right i guess
you're not going you're not attracting
the same types of people that i was
being introduced to i i think none of my
customers are miserable [ __ ] well though
i i met one person in that video who
could speak english and she was super
chill she was really cool yeah yeah
really really nice they were miserable
because they couldn't talk to you but
i just saw how they interacted because i
was getting like live translations in my
ear the whole time and i was like
watching it and it was like
i was like
what was like the stuff they were
talking about was depressing or it was
just kind of how like or just the
atmosphere the atmosphere i don't you
know it was don't get me wrong that
seemed like the club was going well but
like sometimes they would say things and
i was like jesus christ
like you know they would say something
that was like you know they were trying
to like i don't know they were trying to
go for something and the guy was like
yeah
like watching car crashes or something
yeah yeah it's just like oh my god it's
like trying not to cringe compilations
yeah yeah
it was you know
it's weird
it is a weird world
it's strange what's like some of the
weirdest [ __ ] you've seen
i'm sure you've got stories out the ass
for that
then that you're allowed to tell me
obviously
okay keep in mind we have to air this
like a million people yeah
what you
people think yeah when people think
crazy host stories they're going to
think of some crazy we're not on [ __ ]
bbc yeah yeah yeah but also you have to
think about the current people who
employ me as well you know they might
be like oh wow
this is the guy where he
generic as possible yeah okay so some
generic things you've seen in the host
industry or some dodgy things that go on
in the host industry
yeah wow or maybe something you
personally experienced that you thought
was a bit um dodgy
well i guess um this is an interesting
one so the way they do their
shimeko
in japanese so this is the way you
actually boost your numbers within the
industry right um so shime is as i
mentioned in the beginning of the
episode this is when you have people
choose yes their daddy
the more people choose us to your daddy
your your rank gets higher yeah
billboard so they will notice you more
yeah so one way to do that is go to
other clubs like kabakura like female
oriented clubs as your host boys yeah
and then you get all those balls and
stuff yeah exactly and give them your
you know vote and then tell them this is
where i work at
give them your parents you gotta come
here and vote for me and they're like
all right sure and then they come vote
for you it's like presidential campaign
yeah it's like politics
this is literal politics right now but
yeah i guess if you stayed that way
do you have like do you have like a
tagline like that's like yeah jan i will
ask you what you are doing here well
i am a chad my name is jan yeah
wait so so wait so would you did you
have to do that as well like would you
have to go to like girls bars and like
stuff like that be like and like oh
a lot dude my the shot show would like
just take all of us
people who build that night or the
people who are like chilling with other
girls that night yeah yeah you know late
into the evening because um host club
finished at like 12 p.m let's say yeah
and then we would have like a you know
subsidiary bar
subsidiary
why why was it close so earlier why does
it close to 12. there are laws bro you
just take it to a different venue and
you know at that bar it's still same
[ __ ] everything is expensive as [ __ ]
yeah but you know you get to just be a
bit more relaxed and then more intimate
let's say
and at that place if you're staying
there for long chacho would come there
and be like yo guys we're going
somewhere and get the boys and go to the
club let's say after it could be like a
bakura or like whatever
you know establishment you can think of
in tokyo right yeah
and then you know the chacha would pay
for everything i've seen chuchu pay up
to like you know six seven k us
one evening for like three four guys
total you know geez he would just shell
the [ __ ] out
but i suppose like considering the
amount of money that hosts making anyway
that's like that's like yeah the girl
doesn't care bro he's chilling man he's
chilling so you would do that and you
would go around and interact with the
girls at those establishments yeah
supposedly to basically be like hey when
you come to my club next time
choose me well not when but like you're
coming next week right
it's not a suggestion
so you're coming next week tuesday right
what happens if they don't come
yeah i mean nothing you something i'm
going to call the turkish texas
if you don't vote for me
i got a lot of taxi drivers on the line
we're on the plane right now we're
coming and they're not japanese that's
not what's gonna happen but you know if
you know anything about japan
you know
verbal agreements mean a lot yeah in
japan rather than paper signing most
deals are done through
global agreements that's because is that
true i i think a lot of things in japan
done by like on paper agreements from my
experience i mean that's also true but
if you look i think socially speaking
yeah socially and traditionally for
example like
a lot of verbal stuff holds more value
to it especially
it's all about the respect like renowned
family if you're from like a renowned
family for example yeah you don't like
uphold your promise
and you know you risk losing that
[ __ ] reputation for your family yeah
your family will [ __ ] like whip you
bro yeah you know but i mean that was
back in the day right now even even now
bro even now there's just a lot of big
families
right still to this day like a lot of
people who want to respect their like
you know
um yeah i mean not that many anymore but
depending on like the for example if you
look at like really family-owned
businesses
that's how it functions right right like
for example the people who make like you
know
choreography
john describing a pen
she was elegant moved all of her muscles
made me melt and i saw this [ __ ] pan
that was made out of like one hair of
whatever the [ __ ] animal yeah whatever
so anyhow um you know imagine you're
like the supplier of this hide for this
pen and then you're dealing with the
people who make like the holding part
the wooden you know yeah yeah you know
you don't make [ __ ] wooden paper
contracts you make verbal contracts why
because your relationship date back to
like 150 years right right right that's
what i'm talking about but i mean is
that the same as making a verbal
agreement at a goals bar
for you to come to the next now that you
mentioned it for them to come the next
day right like i don't think there's
many girls in the kawakura who are like
oh well i better go to this club i don't
want my family on my house a part of it
does translate though right what i mean
by i'm sure it does but not to the same
capacity not the same capacity not in
the same like respect values but in
terms of like you know if you're if
you're like a you know renowned person
in your bar and you make a promise and
you don't you know protect that or
you know make that come true other
people are going to see you as some
lying bastard right
so you just get outed from the industry
then i guess well not out about you know
like it's bad rumors will spread yeah
yeah you know like
we should make promises right right
right right
i guess well yeah because it's such a
small industry right right right
everybody knows each other
yeah exactly you know i was sucking
roland's dick the entire time but
literally you'll figure it out
the [ __ ]
this doesn't matter bro
so anyhow um
you know i know a few people who have
you know [ __ ] had fun with him
dragged with him in the past so if i
really really really wanted to i could
still get a message across to him
right i could reach out to his [ __ ]
sns matches saying some dude called john
saying this to him
that's how close contact this entire
industry is doesn't matter if you're
like you know the most renowned hostel
or
it sounds like turkish taxi drivers to
me now that you mentioned it bro
[ __ ] you want to fly up my homies
establish my own network oh all the
hosts are turkey's taxi drivers
honestly like where do people talk you
know yeah post club
how much [ __ ] does john know
all of his clients you know
i'm i'm uh i'm curious about uh
how you know you mentioned your club and
you mentioned there's other famous ones
yes sir is it
so first of all how long have clubs been
around two house club sorry uh in japan
and two what's the difference between
like the older ones and the new ones
how long have they been around that's
your first question right yeah like as a
subculture yeah thousands of years bro
thousands of years
i was like no like [ __ ]
wow a while horse club culture has been
around for a while but
when it started popping off i would say
in like the last 15 years right that's
when it started it seems like a really
new thing
looking from the surface to a certain
degree well i think japan has become
more lonely over
technology and well when is there like
birth rate when did their birth rate
start declining right about 10 15 years
ago that makes sense
that makes sense that makes sense so
what's the difference then between like
a club that's been around 50 years you
know how do they do business what's the
difference between that and like how you
know say a club that popped up like two
weeks ago oh
well i was saying for example a club
like you know that hosted you know one
of the most legendary hosts of all time
like rorando
just by hosting them there they can up
their name value meaning
people who don't know anything about
host clubs
they get the club's name into their ear
through social you know right anything
goes on like twitter news [ __ ] ryan
news anything they kind of see that
exposure club i mean there's a lot that
i know you know even though i've never
yeah exactly i don't even know where it
is these [ __ ] vans that drive around
shinjuku oh yeah just
create this horrible music out with like
these oh that's what they are yeah
some of them are horse clubs yeah i
didn't know yeah it's awful
it's horrible fortune to get those too
you know yeah i can imagine there's a
car with your face on it
yeah yeah you know all i hear sometimes
are just like the [ __ ] word like the
political people were just shouting
boosted speakers you can't even hear
what they're saying
yeah that's so annoying
there's also the one that goes around in
like shinjuku all the time that's like
thank you
yeah
i i can't imagine being the truck driver
man like how how long has this i have i
have actually seen like when one of the
vanilla truck drive the trucks went past
i was like i want to get a look of this
like the actual driver's face yeah yo he
looked brain dead
he was literally like it's gonna be that
name from uh caroline the guy on the pc
like you're like
that's what you're looking for yeah so i
go ahead about the differences between
the course yeah so so what what would
you say like is it like a difference in
service or like the the way that they do
it or like rules
i'll say the main difference is
cut
what
this episode is sponsored by boxing
connor what is that special wooden box
you've got there i thought you'd never
ask joey because this is a special gift
just for you is that a wooden boxer it
sure is hold your horses gentlemen what
is this boxu thing you talk about i'm
glad you asked god let me tell you
boxo's a monthly snack box subscription
service that delivers original
assortments of premium japanese snacks
and tea pairings foxu makes such a
perfect and memorable gift for anyone in
your life who appreciates japanese
snacks and culture especially during a
time where people aren't able to travel
as easily as they would like to
gentlemen you know what's special about
boksu this month what is it joey three
tickets to japan boxer's having a
giveaway where one lucky winner will win
a free ticket to japan that's right and
anyone who has subscribed before
december 31st is automatically entered
link is in the description below so you
can check out the terms and conditions
and other methods of entry and another
thing that is super special this month
is the wooden box which is also known as
a kiribaku boxy which i didn't know
about that i knew that what's kitty
buckle wooden box
from now until december 30th you can
receive your next boxu in a special
kiribaku wooden box for an additional
fifty dollars lovingly crafted in the
koga city japan by masuda kirbako so
what are you waiting for you can use
trash taste 10 and the link in the
description below to become eligible to
win the giveaway by subscribing to boxu
the code will get you 10 off your
subscription don't miss out on this
unique opportunity for anyone who
subscribes until december 31st so like i
said get yourself or a special loved one
a kitty bakuboku and check out the link
for a chance to win a free trip to trash
tasteland
back to the show so the main difference
between like a new club that just popped
out versus a club with a long long
history is
how much respect it has from other clubs
surrounding it right so as i mentioned
if you're like a long time club that
means you have at least a few people who
either like came out of your club or
went to your club
and became really popping off you know
why don't like news medias or just
carried your club to the surface right
and that carries a lot of value in the
hosting industry it it's weird to me
that japan
puts hosts on this like pedestal
but then
you know how it is if you're if you're a
woman doing the exact same job reversed
it's like wrong
oh yeah it's like you know you're like
the the scum of society yeah it's
bizarre really because it is very double
standard even if we had that in the west
we i don't think we'd be putting the
hosts on tv and stuff like that but
japan it's just like dude this guy's
sick bro he like talks to girls all day
are you wondering
oh [ __ ] you're disgusting yeah yeah the
[ __ ] yeah sorry i should have mentioned
but i think as well like that's like
going back to like rolling right like i
think the reason why it became like that
is because in a lot of ways yeah you
know i think it's accepted that a guy
can be like that right yeah at least
japanese society
that's a character like yeah this is
good but if one of them acted the same
way i think i think if there was like a
female equivalent of roland it wouldn't
happen the same way unfortunately you do
have good examples of that though you
know a lot of huge cosmetic shot shows
right now coming from quebec backgrounds
right
but like you mentioned
roland's impact on this industry is
impeccable yeah something you cannot
measure with just numbers yeah also he
saw himself as a personality exactly on
tv whereas we haven't really had that
for the female like
no yeah so you join a new club right
let's say uh you're a you're a rookie
you're [ __ ] at your job just terrible
what's the experience i would have being
terrible in like one of the old amazing
perfect respected clubs versus being in
a club that's kind of [ __ ] and like
small and they just kind of like
like even get a job in that sense well
let's say you got it right let's say you
got it and then you started [ __ ] up
like you know you couldn't get any
clients like how would they
because i can imagine that they don't
treat you
they're not like oh oh it's okay it's
okay
but i imagine the one that's like kind
of worse off is like oh dude i mean
the best example i can give is
imagine being in like unknown ass
[ __ ] you know consulting company
versus being in [ __ ] boston
consulting right right right you know
the pressure that's a very specific
example yeah look the pressure you have
at boston consulting doesn't derive from
the fact that you know
you suck but it's because this is the
company you know values we uphold
are you reaching that standard right you
know if you're not we have a thousand
other recruits outside lining up to take
your placement
versus an unknown as club it's like
we could fire you but we'll have nobody
else we're gonna try paying people too
yeah
that's the difference right right
so like is it how dangerous is the
industry
yeah how dangerous well actually that's
a really great um question because
you know
from the old times other host clubs are
known to have a lot of violence involved
in them yeah meaning if you're not
performing well if you're you know
slacking you know
your boss might kind of like slap you
around
and
what do you mean slap around like like
like a little like like that oh my
no bro i'm talking about that you're
sleeping and they'll [ __ ] bash your
head and [ __ ]
you know wait wait like
like [ __ ] good fellas
like even in my host club not not within
there but previous to joining there i've
had
stories told to me from those people
there that you know they were kind of
falling asleep and then they got smacked
in the head so hard that their [ __ ]
tooth chipped and [ __ ]
bro like because i was sleeping yeah
exactly just because they were like not
so you know responsive and whatnot even
within my host club we would have like
meetings to go over like
statistics who was building well there's
a good hedpa you know because even if
you're not billing if you're
contributing so that the girls are
drinking yeah they'll respect you right
because that means you're doing your job
yeah exactly that means you contribute
to the actual revenue all right but if
you're just like you're not even
catching girls outside and when the
girls sit with you you're some boring
ass [ __ ] they're going to
[ __ ] [ __ ] about it
and that's the main way to make you quit
right by keep putting on the spotlight
and be like you [ __ ] suck they can't
just tell you to like [ __ ] off no
because i mean you know that's not the
way that's the way japanese people do it
you know they're what they like shame
you publicly until you quit bro yeah
honestly yeah that's [ __ ] up
truthfully it's so funny i mean i mean
regular companies do that too yeah
that's because they have lifetime
contracts yeah yeah it's like it starts
at school because
if they're willing to like slap you in
the head why aren't they willing to tell
you to not turn up to work tomorrow i
don't know
yeah i love that i was like i have no
like i have no like resistance to like
actually smack you in the back of the
head but i don't have the heart to tell
you to quit
everything if you prevail from this you
know
agonizing pain that's such [ __ ]
bro come on it is a real true phenomenon
where if you're strong enough to prevail
this challenge that's given to you yeah
that means you could become a man i
agree in some sense i don't know about
that i think i only works in anime
tell me you're a [ __ ] as excuse come on
tell me
there is a challenge and there is being
beaten up in your world yes
host industry is not some like you know
[ __ ] sugar coated powder i'm not sure
no no i'm not sounds like i think it is
we've established that it's dodgy as
[ __ ] in there as [ __ ] and yeah you have
to know your you know street knowledge
yeah if you don't have any street
abilities you're gonna get [ __ ] you
know bulldozed over yeah yeah i
understand of course yeah that's a fact
but frightening it is some form of it's
a noble challenge that one must
undertake to become oh no this guy is
that the way i'm putting it or is it i'm
putting it in a way that it's like
rolling in the mud and wrestling until
one of them chokes to death
like you know
that's the kind of that's the kind of
challenge that you have to understand
did you think that analogy was better
i think it reflects the situation or at
least reflects the reality of the
situation you know so
do you think it's [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up but but you also think
there's a point to it yeah absolutely no
it's not [ __ ] up bro no it's no it's
not something
look who am i to judge you literally
just said you're rolling around the mud
until one of those like i appreciate
like like gladiators did that back like
the roman empire look in in any business
right there is a reason as to why the
whole thing transpired to become what it
is
you have to respect what came before you
of course you understand why it's the
way it is that's the whole you know core
of understanding what a culture is
mm-hmm
but then there are you know sometimes
there are cultures that should maybe be
changed just just because just because
something's been established doesn't
mean you can't
i feel japan though i'm sensing some
vocabulary
whatever [ __ ] twitter profile i just
i just i just think generally that's uh
you know i understand why this these
kind of stories can happen in the
industry
that is fun that is not [ __ ] up yeah i
mean
let's just let's just let's just break
this down you're literally trying to say
that getting your teeth kicked in is
my sincere apologies for not making this
clear there is a huge difference between
having a disciplined way of conducting
your business versus
violence because violence is really
frowned upon
yeah no matter what there's
finally a takeover i can agree with you
you're right jan water is wet
how is like xenophobia and racism within
the host uh yeah because i i've heard
there's plenty of the action yeah
because like i've heard that some a lot
of host clubs actually don't let foreign
no no they don't because like what are
they gonna do
well i mean what if they want to have
like a good time trying to like interact
with the locals can't communicate
if you can speak japanese in your forum
would they let you in if you can't speak
japanese and you're a foreigner you have
a chance a chance you have a chance yeah
that's interesting i mean survive the
beating and we'll give you a drink
this is this this is the same with
almost all other japanese businesses
that are nightlife related that is true
foreigner most likely they'll be like
and then not accept you yeah yeah yeah i
mean some restaurants [ __ ] yeah
let alone you know life stuff this is
like going back to the discrimination
thing that i just mentioned like isn't
you know because you're you know you're
a halfu uh am i now yeah oh yes you are
yeah yes yeah
[ __ ] i don't know you'd like to know
where they're all being
like five billion times you know and uh
from what i've seen yeah jerry you could
i'm sure you can uh say if i'm right or
wrong if you don't look 100 in japanese
it's assuming you're like foreign
so how does that you know because that
comes into play that comes into play a
lot in japan
for sure
so how does it come into play in a host
club how many how many times were you
nihongo joseph at a host club every
single time yeah right so
how surely they must in some senses
they're like oh you're not you're not
japanese bro you're like you're like the
gimmick bro yeah yeah yeah yeah each
time each time so did you use that to
your advantage or did you like try and
fight against it
as i mentioned to you guys before i had
no interest in talking to girls who had
no life experience or who had no
interest in life experience so
i would come across some people that say
like you know i asked them you know do
you want to go abroad i've been to this
country you want to know more about it
and they're like now i'm okay with just
staying in japan i'll be like
okay next weirdly weirdly common it
happens a lot bro it happens a lot but
you know i skipped those girls because i
have nothing they want to talk to them
about yeah but until i found find the
people that want to know more about you
know living abroad
yes yeah
that's when i shine
so these these girls we've established
like just how much money is spent in
these host clubs like
how how do these clients have these this
much money because like as we as we've
established not everyone is like old you
know mature yeah successful
businesswoman how did these like how do
these like women in their early twenties
like spend like stupid amounts of money
so this comes back to the discussion
about the demographic of the host club
so most of them are in the nightlife and
nightlife in japan pays a lot yeah like
substantial amounts so they have a huge
amount of disposable income for such
expenditures and that's what they decide
to spend it on i mean like every week it
seems like ex-celebrity is caught in a
girl's bar so i mean clearly uh no
shortage of clientele and given the
frequency of these girls piles i mean
they're everywhere in town yeah no doubt
that uh yeah bro they're not struggling
no it seems like you know everyone pays
each other like back right it's it's the
same artist
right right it's just like yeah there's
a lot of money but i'm gonna be paying
that money back to you oh it's it's it's
you okay now now it's your turn to pay
me
i i think like a cool like experiment
would be like if you leave like a little
mark on like a thousand yeah
and see if it eventually comes back into
your hand right like that that could be
kind of a good one yeah i'm sure it
happens
yeah sure but the core of the business
does lie in that though you know right
it's that the knife life people support
each other right right so do you have
time to spend the money that you earn or
does it just go back into the industry
not for sure bro because and as i was
mentioning i don't do this full-time
like i never did it full-time i mean
talking about like hosts in general yeah
like full-time hosts like do they have
enough time to like spend it on
themselves or look like just
if if you're at like the you know top
one percent percentile kind of thing
yeah
you barely have time to sleep honestly
yeah right yeah so they they just get
like no days off right like spend it on
themselves i had a few benders with the
number one guy back in the day and like
his day would go like this
you know i would see him at the host
club after his like hair makeup and you
know he would do his own makeup in the
bathroom i'll call him like all the
names i can while he's doing his makeup
and then you know once the night starts
i see him bringing out all his girls
until like midnight and then from there
he would take me to the subsidiary bar
where we drink for like three four hours
and then we would meet up with another
separate group of girls
that are just like the late night crew
you know after like 3 4 a.m that just
want to hang out until like 10 a.m you
know all right and then we just go hard
until that and then this guy would not
sleep and go for a lunch
okay with another you know girl he's
already like seeing yeah yeah and he
would have a lunch with her and
sometimes go to disneyland and [ __ ]
without sleeping bro how does this man
not not look like a human rat bro like
bro
[ __ ] dude i do that for one night bro
and i look like i've been hit by a car
yeah i look dreadful yeah it's difficult
stuff man so he goes to sleep at like
3 4 p.m
wakes up in two three hours
you know same thing again gets your hair
done get your makeup while i'm laughing
at him you know same thing over and over
jesus
so like i guess from what it sounds like
the lifespan of the host can't be that
long normally surely depends on how you
conduct yourself yeah well so well if
you're in that side if you're in that
cycle
really comes in strong because this he
is known to never drink
oh he has the helpers with him all the
time yeah and like he's the [ __ ]
definition of you know to become a host
you don't have to drink yeah all you
have to have is good conversational
skills and the people who come to the
club only have to come just because they
want to chat with you right and they
want to gain something out of it right
right so become like a life coach almost
why is it that they have to buy drinks
to like pay the hosts can can you not
just like [ __ ] just give them money
i think it's because if you give someone
money you're way less likely to like
give someone money if you're buying
drinks it's like feeding it's a gift for
you
and and you know you both win you're
getting the drink you want it's like
buying rounds at a pub yeah if i give
you a tenner i'm like expect photography
for an hour gone i'm gonna be like [ __ ]
i'm looking at the clock every 10
minutes but if you finish your drink i'm
like you want another drink on yeah yeah
i mean it's i think it's because that
atmosphere just wouldn't get as much
money
is that the right spot on analysis my
friend okay there you go
no because like i maybe compare this to
you know
like going to a strip club or something
and buying a dance that is like money
being exchanged
right and that's i mean i'm sure because
like i think it's the same thing right
like i guess for a lot of girls like
getting to talk to a person is like
paying for a service right yeah kind of
similar to life at a strip club for
example when you're hanging out with
your friends right yeah if you want to
keep hanging out what do you do
buy another drink right yeah buy a round
yeah another drink exactly so so how
much how much are these drinks marked up
as i said times 10 of their original
price that's what time that's like times
30. and that was that was chaser that
was like their water the strong zero
which is like a nine percent drink they
drank as like a chaser oh my god it was
like oh that drink was so strong i'm
gonna drink some water oh it's strong
zero yeah because the one thing i always
like know about like the host thing is
like the the donkey tower yeah yeah all
the champagne towels yeah oh yeah yeah
like how many of those did you have to
do
was that's just like
okay
because i always thought like
how many birthdays you go how much how
much is for one because is it like one
is it just one bottle of dom perignon
that you had just before or it's like
multiple bottles multiple bottles
depending on the tower that you so
multiple bottles of don perignon which
are marked up 10 times the
what price it like ten thousand yeah i
mean like how much for one for at your
at the club you worked out
when you got a a champagne tower how
much would a girl have to spend if i was
a girl and i want to buy you a don pinar
perry on champagne tower how much would
i have to spend so again this kind of
requires some explaining because
if you're stingy as [ __ ] and you don't
you want to build like the you know
smallest tower you can
but again there's different levels like
how many glasses like exactly it's all
about you know like showcasing yeah all
right the more glasses of tower you have
the more glamorous it looks yeah so even
if you're building half of it with cheap
alcohol in the other half with actual
premium alcohol yeah as soon as it looks
big enough yeah it does the job huh
right so even if it's someone who has
like a you know like only like two three
patrons who's only willing to shell out
a total maximum maybe like 10k us for
your birthday
we're just talking about like 40
commission of people earning like over
50k so that's per birthday yeah come on
imagine the glamorous [ __ ] what's how
was that day what's what's the most one
yeah yeah what's the most expensive one
you've ever received or something or
seasons or scenes or something what's
the most you've seen someone spend on
one night bro like this is i will be
proud to tell the story to the day i die
but my number one homie yeah yeah he
on this one day
his 30th birthday yeah he racked over
200k us
in
[ __ ] what did you do on your 30th
i just i just hang out with the boys
they bought me a [ __ ] drink it cost
like a [ __ ] tenner could have got 200
[ __ ] okay what's going on oh joey's
expectations
finally an upside to turning 30. what
the [ __ ] i'm like 200k so that's 200k is
40 percent right so you go you you get
to get like not me
yeah yeah exactly
and you know chris
when you're reaching that level um of
course you can still have champagne
towers that like surround itself yeah
because the trick is to just make it
three-dimensional so you feel more space
yeah you know um but
you want to be more glamorous when
you're hostile so we hired like a you
know ross royce at the entrance of the
club we have like [ __ ] firework kind
of stance at the end saying she like
make it look like a wedding celebrities
you literally got pyrotechnics when
going into the club bro it was so much
fun though you know yeah
it sounds like the beginning of like a
wwe or something you know [ __ ] stoned
from the rolls
saddest thing is well the hostel can
only go on a date and come to the venue
in a roll stores with only one girl
oh my god
so you better pick well so the thing is
the thing is when you're the number one
that means you have host buddies or i
mean sorry the ladies that are saving up
for your occasion for like months all
right you know like very sad
dude like after this day you know for
like the next two three weeks it's all
about the conversations like oh i saved
up for like eight months and i still
couldn't get the position you know like
it's like oh my god
i guess i guess that makes sense why the
host club you went to was just like
everyone was depressed maybe it was
right before right after a book yeah
exactly everyone's saying she's supposed
to be this and no he's getting it all
the girls are like ah i was i was eighth
in line finally an enemy that can rival
v tubers
who wants more
yo you think these rainbow super chats
are like impressive like
200 thousand dollars
on towers
beat your heart out
maybe maybe that's the
next maybe that's the thing
i mean it is i mean i guess it's just it
is the same thing it's just digitally
yeah that's right
i guess that's what super chats are
let's just get attention from people
there's probably there's definitely some
of them that are like you know
organizing one-on-ones where you can buy
time oh yeah of course of course that's
the only difference right rarely though
yeah really right now yeah yeah i can't
become more of a thing who's your
favorite youtuber why you asking
with like four women around here he's
like they're sending a super chat away
oh my god
brother not tonight there's women on me
right now she wanted to tell you that
you're my favorite v tuber he's five
bucks
who's your favorite then um
ahoy
yes
your money
money she was my favorite for a while
yeah
who's your favorite why you asking me to
ask me these questions don't ask me i
feel like i know but no no you don't
i know you just sensing about it you
know no don't bring this up don't
[ __ ] pick me up
i if you're listening
tame tame your friend
come get your mans
but uh i guess like so you don't do
hosting anymore right are you yeah i
don't belong to a club anymore you know
wait what does that mean
uh so
this is like a deposition it's like
you're not answering the question about
answering the question you can take
you can
so you know previous clients since i've
been doing this for almost an hour right
now yeah like the people have
you know
met along the way
at this point they're just there to you
know drink with me to get live updates
because i've known this is an old friend
yeah like i've known there for like
almost 10 years some of them you know
all right that's great that means you
guys are being invited to weddings and
[ __ ] you know of the girls that are
getting married you know
like and i went to some
why should not what dude how does how do
you when you when you spread people at
the wedding how did that go were they
like oh this is jen this is the guy oh
yeah yeah
wait how did the wife explain to the
husband that's what i was gonna ask bro
so for example like there was a lady who
was
back in the day she was in her late
university time yeah and i was telling
her you know like you should do exchange
go to other countries
live life giving life advice yeah
exactly and then a few years later you
know i find out that she's marrying
somebody she met overseas thanks to her
experience abroad and then she says she
got to do this just because i [ __ ]
gave her the encouragement to go abroad
right i'm skipping like the whole arc
here but i i caught him that's the end
result here i imagine the husband was
like you're inviting what a host
is this like ncr's like her husband
meets me and then i talk about you know
the way we met and you're hustling what
kind of
quality conversations we have
nobody's like you know like suspecting
anything you know yeah because i'm like
i'm honest but did you tell them that
you were tell him that you were a host
dude that's how the wife introduced
like you know the same that's it the
wife's got some balls
chris like i've never seen something
with such as like big dick energy yeah
hi honey
hi honey he's hi honey here's another
man that i spent a lot of money on uh
before i met you
but are we met because of this man dude
like interestingly i have a lot of that
you know even with my ex-girlfriends i
still see some of them japan is wack
with their parents
and we still hang out and [ __ ] yeah and
that's still the case with hostel stuff
like some people that don't even see me
anymore just want to hang out with their
new boyfriends
yeah what melee i see what you're
writing yeah uh
yeah dude
we can't say that out well i'm gonna ask
that yeah we let off settle can you just
say yes or no to me i mean you can't
hint at it
[Music]
the wedding isn't as innocent as it
seems to say that i mean you know
everyone you know the hosts are not just
for talking right but you can't say that
i don't know i know i know i know
elaborate your sentence
what what are what are part of the hosts
responsibilities it's not all disneyland
that's what i'm saying
it's not all
are there more perks to the job uh
that's uh other than just that
so we both get perks yeah
to answer your question kind of directly
but indirectly
it involves a lot of mental
psychological you know like [ __ ]
meaning
if you know what somebody wants and you
give it to them straight away you might
get them
to be bored of you and then they might
not come back for more
okay so the strategy for some cases is
to tease and edge
but
what are you laughing at man what are
you laughing at it's like [ __ ] bonnie
stinson from how i met your mother it's
like
it's insane
i understand that it's the job right
yeah
it's one side of it though one side of
it
on the other side there are some people
that don't want you for what you're you
know no i i understand that like they
just did your conversation exactly
they're there for just for your company
and so if you push for it on a drunken
evening you might just [ __ ] ruin your
relationship and then they might not
come back
so there's a lot that you have to think
about and this is with any other social
encounter you know if you think somebody
is beautiful and they're wonderful and
you feel like you want to spend the
night with them
and they're down for it as well
and it's yeah i was gonna say because
you know obviously obviously it's the
only thing that they they pay for is the
drinks
i feel like i'm sitting with a bunch of
virgin
i'm just really enjoying you trying to
explain yourself listen listen i okay i
understand right you're all they pay for
is the drinks but what you're trying to
do is secure that they keep coming for
those strengths exactly yeah you know
you do what you got to do i understand
that business is business and it's
ruthless you know and it's it's childish
or naive to think that that it's not how
the business works right right i've said
that it doesn't mean i can't be like
that's [ __ ] up
just to make myself clear the way i
conduct myself is with my wits and
intelligence and yeah unique ability of
talking about [ __ ] that they have no
idea about which is right you are you
are a worldly host yeah yeah exactly
miss award white [ __ ] people right
yeah yeah
that's how i you know do my thing
but there are some people that of course
push their you know physical attributes
right
yeah yeah yeah
and they fall into dilemma where you
know
if i don't give it to her now
she might not come back next time but if
i give it to her now
she definitely won't come back you know
exactly right right you know if you're
like this and you suck at it
it's gonna happen no i i totally get it
you know that's that's just the
environment and the industry of the host
club yeah but you know i'm sure to a lot
of people watching and you know some
people who are not versed in this
world it seems otherworldly it is almost
like for them it's like what sex what's
to be fair i think i think one not even
one of the most underrated like
uh different aspects of japanese culture
is the nightlife and the the whole the
you know the host industry and all that
like i think it's
people are like oh it's so wacky they
have kfc on christmas it's like
like the real weird differences between
the west is the [ __ ] that don't get
doesn't get talked about
completely different and you know in
some ways i you know i as a you come
into this with a farm perspective and
you judge it as such but i feel like in
some ways it's unfair of us to judge and
be like that's that's [ __ ] weird what
they do it's like well i mean that's
what they do that's that's what they've
chosen to do and that's how they do the
business is it does it sound predatory
at times a little bit but i mean you
know it's my perspective you know yeah i
mean and you know again like as you were
saying like it is a thing that i i think
again japan is so good at maintaining a
culture yeah right and like maintaining
ways to do a culture where sometimes
ancient artists yeah yeah
yeah where sometimes you know
they get so they get so encapsulated in
holding on to this specific cultural
thing yeah that they almost fail to
realize that you know what maybe it
doesn't really fit into society today's
standards right like that's the whole
reason why the [ __ ] facts machine
still exists right
great point right maybe it's like you
know like they don't realize that you
know they just think themselves yeah
it's [ __ ] up but this is how it came
to be this this is what makes japanese
life japanese nightlife they never stop
to think to themselves
hey maybe this is [ __ ] up yeah you
know just just a bit although you know
hosts are promoted on tv
you know i'm under the impression that
almost on like a national level it's
something that they try and keep kind of
hidden and that that like they they're
not too proud of
would you would you say i guess that's
the whole reason why we go
open your eyes so like over the past 10
years would you say that hosts and host
clubs become less popular or more
popular
really massively why would you say that
again thanks to roland kind of people
who yeah mainstream and showcase that
becoming a whole is it just rolling
though
or is it maybe because the whole
subculture of host clubs have just
become a little bit more open to like a
general public maybe yeah it's becoming
like but that what helped to achieve
what you just talked about is
through
manga anime
right a lot of these media's picked up
on that and they're glorified right yeah
they make it look like yeah it's
actually fun or on high school
like all in high school
where like this guy who does whatever
the [ __ ] he wants in school and
everybody's like mesmerized by himself
exactly that you know where does that
drive from the core of that principle
comes from the hostile mentality of
being this you know superior untouchable
[ __ ] you know
more mighty being in the japanese
meanwhile they're throwing up in the
matsuya parking yeah yeah after they've
had a few one too many tricks so i mean
to pick your points
doesn't show you
the core roots of the thing you know is
the same yeah that's right
yeah it's it's interesting because it's
just so [ __ ]
yeah
it's like you're literally
yeah but it's like it's just kind of
crazy to think that there are people who
literally put their life on the line to
like maintain a facade because well you
know that's what gets them the money
right yeah yeah yeah
i mean it's not the only japanese
industry that does that right you look
at the [ __ ] idol industry oh
it's entirely based on that's like
maintaining an image and dude i'd say
that's ten times more toxic bro
yeah yeah coming from
i mean
it says it says a lot it says
which is why i'm like i don't even think
you're wrong in saying that after the
stories i felt my psychology comes from
this and i think this also relates to
you know other idol related industries
that are still popping up to this day
which is educating your audience
right your audience is your main sort of
income right at the end of the day
and within the idol industry they're so
strict about everything that you know
females do the relationship they have
with the boys or like any kind of
interactions they have
it's almost toxic
yeah but why does that even exist that's
because the industry standard is bred to
be that way yeah yeah
so you have to educate your own audience
so that you're more free you're more
open you're more willing to accept you
know radical ideas into your business
you feel like no one's no one's willing
to take that risk yeah are they well the
companies aren't no they're not the
companies are well like asian dudes in
suits bro like
how are you gonna teach them new tricks
man
you're not gonna i get what you're
saying you just couldn't have said it in
the worst way possible you know like
i guess you're you're asian right it's
okay
i'm brutal in the way i carry myself
forward well i guess you have to be to
survive as a host right at times like i
mean generally as a businessman too bro
my current job is mostly about
convincing people to do [ __ ] that i want
them to right
why make it sound so sinister
[ __ ] this is one thing i promised myself
not to do to seem like a sinister
[ __ ] malicious bastard well i mean
like
the thing is like i get what you're
saying right because especially when it
comes to the idol industry where it's
like you know industries don't want to
take a stab at like a new idea because
again it goes back to that whole thing
of like maintaining tradition right
maintaining this is how we've been doing
it it's been working so far let's do it
idols can't [ __ ] say anything because
the moment they're like um i have a
radical idea and they're like all right
bye-bye bye-bye
say bye to your career say goodbye and
then if a fan says uh hey maybe this is
kind of [ __ ] up then the community
gets on his ass and goes like ah get the
[ __ ] out then right so it's like no one
wins there's no space for change until
yeah as you said like at the end of the
day you need to get like the entirety to
be like oh yeah this [ __ ] maybe we
should change it and that changes over
time you know though that can't be
something that's done overnight but like
at the same time
who's going to take that first step
right because it's that's a massive risk
and i'm ten years of the business bro
in whatever format that is whether it's
you know reality
they want to risk everything that
they've built up over time
but just like
they're not gonna do that right that's
that's the issue that is that is
unfortunately the issue unless you have
someone like super smart like again like
roland right like i guess he's the
greatest it takes a [ __ ] person like
roland to really shake things up yeah
the example i want to give here is from
naruto
[Laughter]
are you serious
if you if you if you
if you say believe it i will actually
smack you wait
you did not just dead ass look me in the
face and say that chat no no no no
no no
do tell don't lose hope on me here bro
okay so explain yourself
you guys know itachi right
yes we know he taught you
where are you going
spoilers i can't spoil it too much if
you haven't watched it after all this
time [ __ ] you
i haven't watched naruto what you guys
know i haven't watched an outro no we
don't how did you pop off on youtube
by not
watching what did you do
you know what i did you give me hope bro
why me you give me hope that in five
years maybe i can be like
why do you want to be like me well no
you can't because you've seen naruto
shh yeah so you have no chance
of life yeah okay you should go and tell
us about allergy then
well tell us about it there's no
interest
yeah he's not going to kill him you need
to worry about he's not going to care
i'm going to watch it can you guys
refresh me on what the main topic is
you were about to give some life advice
concerning italy yeah and naruto why
though
pioneer or something you are quite drunk
you finished you finished it
guys please be sure unless i get to this
point
okay soul breast daily tell us the story
so basically you know hitachi
sacrificed his whole life being for the
greater good that he believed in
a shoe he had to fill in at a age that
you know even he had no understanding or
conscious about okay stop laughing [ __ ]
go on go on go on just
stop laughing [ __ ]
it's so hard to sound smart when you're
talking
countless historical figures who
sacrificed their entire existence for a
cause and out of all of them you chose
[ __ ]
he's very well suited though okay well
go on then go on make your point
so he was terrified
he sacrifices him himself for
pioneer we were talking about pioneers
who shake up the [ __ ] industry he
sacrificed everything and then you said
itachi sacrificed his entire life
exactly so
for example in the naruto verse right if
hitachi didn't do what he did nobody
would have come to realization of you
know the whole
like the dilemma of following the past
and continuing the path you do leading
to the same outcome continuing the
lineage right yeah exactly because you
know the whole susquehanna people and
the naruto
people sorry
i just have this you're talking about
the uchiha class
the woman's sitting down the football
stadium the guys in the here
you know with the host club and they're
here it's like they're where they are
sacrificed his life he's like for the
greater good he's talking about how he
[ __ ] was like you need life
experience he's like so naruto
he took off the weights it was insane
bro he took them off and he should have
been there
it changed history
okay
so
you were saying so he sacrifices himself
for the good of the uchiha family
exactly and right greater good not even
uh
i'm so sorry he clearly loves naruto i
do though i honestly i [ __ ] read the
manga did you you didn't [ __ ] you so you
know that that's what i consider the you
know like
the core medium ass manga if you haven't
read the manga and you just watched them
anime you know
you ain't true [ __ ] fat
okay in my book so you know to those
people who watch berserk anime they
don't read the manga and you consider
yourself a fan
you better die i mean why are you going
off on that face
what happened to the life advice
the life advice here is that so if
itachi didn't take the path he did we
would have never reached the conclusion
that you know like chu mas
yeah coming together to understand each
other will be a solution i know it's
such a cheesy [ __ ] and you know naruto
gives you that but
at the end of the day that's what it
came down to right it's actually going
to break that path right all right let's
listen to the companies
so what you're saying is every industry
needs an itachi exactly
exactly you might sacrifice yourself
your own being your own career but it's
for the greater good of reaching uh you
know
a beautiful speech
thanks thanks for coming is ted talk uh
itachi yeah you buy me a drink now you
have to buy me drink now
we'll have to buy you a drink now for
that life advice no no not a champagne
towel not a champagne towel or buy your
normal drink at a normal bar i'm waiting
for you guys at my next birthday
would you okay okay hypothetically right
we'll be kicked out yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh my god
we can't get in so unfortunately
hypothetically though would you even
would you even accept if i if i did
actually buy you a champagne towel [ __ ]
you bro okay
you know i thought you were going to be
like a bro and be like no that happened
the way you shook your head i was like
he was just like
yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] our friendship you know i
wouldn't even consider it it never
popped into his head because that
happens a lot actually what what
the homies inviting their other homies
to boost your numbers and not just boost
your numbers but to drink with you
because as i said a lot of the most
successful this woman was born as [ __ ]
bro
yeah that's the case because as i said
most successful hosts they're so busy in
the evening that like even if you're
good homies you don't get to drink with
that guy right so sometimes you're like
bro
i want to i want to drink with you
you know i'm going to your club and
you're like yeah sure bro just pay the
price and come over this is like mid
maxing
maxing socially i get to hang out with
my bros and i get paid yeah exactly but
usually what you do is the money they
pay you that gets into your pocket you
kind of give it back to them in the next
drinking don't make it oh yeah yeah all
right you pay for them yeah yeah yeah
you can't be total social [ __ ] so
what you're saying is if i bought you a
dom perignon champagne tower for your
birthday you will happily say hell yeah
but then you'd buy me drinks
bro see me paying you back for the rest
of [ __ ] time
i don't even want to know how much that
is yeah right they probably go for like
like more than 10k right like 10 huh
maybe six digits 100k
some places are we talking jpy or
dollars dollars
six digits yeah is not like six it's
like louis martin kind of [ __ ] bro like
so it exists he does oh my god
could you imagine spending a hundred
thousand dollars on a dude for his
birthday
no i can't even he might be spending a
hundred thousand dollars
yeah other than like a house that you're
investing in or something imagine you're
the daughter of a billionaire right
mm-hmm yeah then what are you going to
do your life is all about
spending money waiting to marry the
right guy yeah well that's that's a
totally different world yeah that's
we're not we're not the daughter of a
billionaire you know i know i know but
i'm just giving you a perspective yeah
another life maybe another life yeah or
the life indeed
jesus christ yeah so like you're
starting a twitch right oh yeah yeah
yeah you're finally gonna have an
internet presence yeah indeed finally
hopefully yeah i mean like we've focused
on the host aspect but uh jan has a lot
of varied stories in a lot of aspects in
your life it's he's not just he's not
just an ex-host
host freelance host now you've done a
lot of [ __ ] and uh we've been trying to
convince him for the longest time to
start an irl stream i mean hopefully
whatever you want to stream i mean
hopefully this trash days episode has
proven that like jan has the chops to be
like a really interesting internet
personality you're a [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] character you are such a [ __ ]
person
sometimes i'm just like i just need to
like give you a mic and just let you
talk and just like
i hope so man so you're signing a stream
right or twitch
above check it out on twitch what are
you going to do just play games or like
well
i don't really want to play games
so what i have planned is every sunday i
want to do something called
controversial sundays
where i test the limits of twitch and
see how how much are you going to be
banned so yeah i'm just going to take
over to band on twitch that's what i
want to do
you're doing a twitch page
if i do get banned for the [ __ ] of it
yeah why not oh my god look i just
wanted to get your dick out what are you
gonna yeah what do i have to lose
i just wanna have fun on twitch bro i
just wanna have one i wanna
the reason i don't think i'm doing it
before you started yeah why are we
promoting a twitch channel that might
get banned we can all have fun together
oh my god
look so all i want to do is talk about
really [ __ ] up subjects on sundays
you know get my take if i can't get any
of your takes that'll be great but if
you don't oh no no you are not getting
outside
i'm not sacrificing my career for you
i'm sorry but by suckling on these sweet
teats of social clout that i'm getting
from you guys
hopefully i can get other smaller time
people who want to call out with me to
just talk about some [ __ ] up subjects
on sundays that'll be great
maybe you should uh i think it's like
ex-hamster i think yeah you can like ex
videos i think is like a good website
yeah i heard chatterbait has a really
good idea yeah
you can talk about whatever the [ __ ] you
want there and not get banned for sure
lively he's pretty good live leak yeah
that's great i mean how [ __ ] up we
talking oh oh no john i was expecting
like a nice warm
welcome i mean you know when you said
when you told us that when you were like
hey guys i i want to i want to start
switch channel you know in my head i was
like oh yeah you know like
yes
he's going to play some games like any
other person
bro as i mentioned to be a hostel you
have to distinguish yourself this is
someone on the street so you can just go
say the n word on a live stream
is that how your brain functions
i i i literally don't know like yeah
you said you're gonna try your hardest
to get banned i'm gonna try my hardest
to go towards the edge of getting banned
and not bad okay so one i guess like one
question to wrap up uh this whole host
club thing is like because you said that
the host club side of things has like
grown massively in the past five ten
years whether that be because of roland
or not you know is up for debate but
like as someone who again used to be in
that and is in no longer anymore like
where do you see it going in like the
next five ten years like will it become
more mainstream mainstream as mainstream
as it can be or will it just be like
forever this subculture
difficult question because
as i mentioned roland had a huge impact
on the industry right right
he brought it to the mainstream right
due to the current unfortunate situation
that's running the whole world um
you know the intimacy of host clubs are
really limited
you have to wear you know masks and you
have to have like face barriers and
stuff yeah how romantic is it yeah a lot
of people are kind of
not so
yeah certifies to go to these clubs
anymore mean the whole like cover
control nightlife area just got
absolutely [ __ ] because yeah yeah
exactly
so that is a huge
obstacle
but a lot of you know places are finding
their way around it
whether by doing like you know streams
actually so holster club streams yeah
wow where on my twitch and stuff or um
stuff on youtube or on youtube yeah
whole source we're going to send us some
links later yeah i want to see these
sure bro yeah so people are doing their
own but mostly like individual hostels
are doing their own thing because right
right they do know that building your
own brand is more important than
building the company's brand
yeah
kind of like following in roland's
footstep
like i'm really glamoring this guy but
like he really really had a huge impact
on the whole industry man right yeah you
know the way he just brought in ideas
and showcase the world that the way he
wants to do his business can actually
viable mm-hmm
yeah there's a huge potential in the
future though yeah yeah yeah definitely
of course it's not going to dwindle away
no i don't know that's perfect i think
so
but uh yeah thanks for coming on chad
this has been uh there's been a wild
ride this has been a very interesting
episode yes
10 minutes huh
but like where can people find you on
twitch right what's your username on
twitch on twitch twitter yeah i was all
the same on twitter twitch twitter
instagram what's the other one the
prominent that people use youtube
facebook youtube
yeah everything is such kebab
guy sushi sushi kebab because i i i i
when you say it's like kebab
sushi kebab reason of japanese of
turkish and you're a guy [ __ ] and i'm a
guy so sushi kebab guy you can't miss it
all right go check him out i guess uh
link's in the description and uh look at
all these patrons yeah yeah so many of
them look at all of them who's your
favorite who's your favorite oh that guy
right there he's passed away who would
you buy a drink for
no one who who just you buy them a drink
who deserves the champagne tower anyone
that has the name that said with a and x
why why i don't just random
well hopefully there's an axe out there
hopefully yeah
you deserve a huge hug and a kiss from
me
mind you he has finished a half a bottle
of gin by myself because [ __ ] didn't
want to dream with me
thank you for joining us yeah if you are
if you want to support the show make
sure to go over to our page on
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify go check out jan and uh thanks
for coming dude thank you bro yeah thank
you very much for coming on man thank
you for having me pleasure come on come
here
pleasure my pleasure
can i stick it in this too because you
know you promised this um when this
episode is coming out or right after it
comes out me and connor
we'll be doing a react episode on twitch
are we going to react to it yes all
right
we'll react to it all right oh my god
all right thanks for watching guys i'll
see you in the next one bye
[Music]
you